this show is brought to you by the cash
app the number one finance app I'd
finance I'm so number one finance app in
the App Store you probably know cash of
is the easiest way to send money to your
friends but the cash up does way more
than that cash app also comes with the
cash card a free debit card that comes
with boosts which are like instant
rewards for shopping at all the places
you already love you can get up to ten
percent off your entire purchase at door
- and even save money every time you
shop at Whole Foods Target and more I
was trying to practice this in Russian
that gosh shop nope didn't go as well as
it did in my head why are you doing I
don't know I was like shoot I'm gonna do
it after you're gonna cash the same
Russian accent why Russian - ah I don't
think I want to get a shop the couch I I
really was into this earlier for some
reason it got in my head but regardless
of how it's pronounced it's easy it's a
very easy way to try and grow your money
with the new investing feature unlike
investing tools that force you to buy
entire shares of stock cash app lets you
instantly invest as little or as much as
you want this way you can still own a
piece of any stock with just one dollar
brokerage services are provided by cash
app investing a subsidiary of square and
member si PC I'm also excited to be
working with cash app to support one of
my favorite organizations The Trevor
Project I have a project that's better
no gosh stop
I don't think we should do that in a
Russian accent that a project oh yeah
that's a good point
when you sign it for the cash app and
use some promo code Whitney not only
will you instantly receive $10 but cash
app will also donate $10 to The Trevor
Project an amazing organization that
provides crisis intervention and suicide
prevention services to the LGBTQ youth
across America and we love it download
the cash app from the app store to dock
I really wish we had been rolling a
second ago because Benton was doing the
thing that makes me so mad
you were your Squier use just squeezing
is it no I don't have any sense
I agree but what were you just doing
what was that yes yes we're just doing
this maybe earth out like a cartoon
villain yeah I was just pulling on my
beard a little bit why I was reading I
don't know I just do that sometimes I
have seen people where when you're
talking to them they will pop a zit on
their face
well that's wild mid-conversation they
just started squeezing at zits while
they're talking to you if you're
listening you can't see what I'm doing
but it's just as disgusting as you think
where people will squeeze zits without
like in public yeah that's gross it's
fucking disgusting times up I'm just not
doing that you but sometimes you pull
out your beard
I do that a lot okay what is that I
don't know do you see that you're
pulling the skin on your face away from
your skull how upsetting that could be
to someone that has to talk to you yeah
but I have a lot of skin there but it's
great you're just you're pulling your
skin around well someone's uh get here
but we weren't talking I was reading I
know but I've never seen you were just
staring at me I've wait there's this and
we've gotten sloppy as a species we're
pulling at our skin while we're having
conversations that weirds me out what am
I to start pulling in my eyebrows Wow no
I didn't sometimes see when I read you
do do that yeah but you do do it
sometimes in conversation really yeah I
don't think people know when you have
like a habit you don't know you're doing
it I don't know maybe it makes me feel
what are you doing you have bugs in your
eyebrows and you're pulling on I've we
do that's all I think about when I think
about eyebrows now that I know that we
but they're not just in your eyebrows
where else are they they're on your
cheeks around your nose your lips your
eyelashes oh good there's thousands of
them thousands yeah in a study of twenty
nine people that they did a hundred
percent of them had mites I'd like to
know what city that was in first of all
I feel like that's gonna oh they were
randomly selected okay cuz I'm gonna say
there's some cities I feel like you're
not more bugs in your eyelashes yeah
twenty nine people from 29 different
cities had thousands of bugs
tiny microscopic 100 percent of them had
thousands of microscopic mites isn't it
cool I I don't I just I don't think
about it until someone starts pulling at
their face or touching their eyebrow in
front of me and I'm like you're killing
the mites well at night time they come
on a rescues mites
at nighttime they come out and breed
when we're sleeping mites are fucking
lying eggs at the same time while we're
sleeping mites are fucking and laying
eggs in our eyelashes yeah and eating
all your dead skin they eat your dead
skin okay
oh yeah yo just during the day oh so
that's there's like that you know
there's circadian rhythm yeah I looked
it up for you good I knew you'd want to
know this is Tim I can't like I have a
little I've never been like this I'm not
a germaphobic person I don't care you
know you see me I pick up dog shit and
throw in like I don't care like I spent
a lot of you off the same dish out of
the scene I do a Reese's but me sterling
my beard is disgusting why does
everybody think that's weird like who
was yelling at me about it that was over
because I had cooked pasta
I mean oh that was me yeah cause he's
the only person ever seen I was cooking
in a bucket of butter you call her pan
pot a pot I don't know a vessel the wok
you know why it's like a pot and I
cooked I like pasta in it poured the
pasta you know there's some little
pieces of pasta left step you're not
telling the story correct you cooked
pasta in it the day before you put your
sauce in the pan yeah you stir it then
you put that in the sink the next day
you use that pot with the sauce in it
and we're boiling soup in it you poured
soup for my seeds in it i boiling mad I
don't think there's anything wrong with
reusing a pot there is when there's
literal rotten food in it it's not
rotten it was what's inside good pasta
sauce sugar it's just sugar
normally you dry it all pasta sighs that
would you ask for it restaurant hey do
you have any old pasta sauce you can
sprinkle on top of this for me I don't
you know I don't go anywhere so if I did
it's no telling what I do at a
restaurant I don't think that's bad I
don't know I think that we are such germ
phobic people in general and we're too
anal retentive
yeah you're one
I'm not an alert ended when it comes to
food when it comes to germs shit like
that like I use old dishes who cares the
dirtiest thing on the planet is your
fucking phone which you put up to your
face every day all day I'm not talking
on the phone that often new extra yards
but do you do it like this do you hold
it out like an speakerphone no I try to
not talk on the phone at all and like
your don't person closing the phone just
really yeah that's sad I mean I text
people but I don't it's okay we're
donating to the trevor project guys I
don't need yeah they will talk to you on
the phone I just am in general I feel
like we need to do like a software
update on our personal hygiene in the
workplace I had to work on a job
yesterday and I would say 30% of the
people I interacted with had chapped
lips that were so chapped that I was
physically ill having to talk to them I
was looking at dried like crusty skin
you know how like it gets over like on
the top of the lip too so there's a
little like cracks and when they're
talking you're like anxious that their
lip is gonna split open and like start
bleeding you got to lube up your lips
there's no excuse to have chapped lips
right I don't look at a horror movie
every time you talk to me Oh cuz you're
not sure you're like is that a herpe is
your lip dry like do you like you can
loan someone gum if they have bad breath
but like you can't really offer to loan
someone your lip balm if they have
chapped lips get please down that's
disgusting and then I'm a comedian I
like to make people laugh but then when
people have chapped lips I don't want to
make them laugh because I'm worried that
their face is gonna split open so I'm
gonna start really hard to not be funny
they just turn into the Joker in an
environment where I'm supposed to be
funny and I'm just like I'm not making
jokes because I'm worried that all these
people's faces are gonna fall off it's
looking at chapped lips makes me so
upset for some reason because it's such
an easy fix you know and I think I think
a lot of guys don't understand that you
cannot like you have to put on lip balm
right when you got a shower that's what
guys do they just wet their lips in the
shower and then don't put lotion on it
you only see guys with dry lips I don't
see a lot of girls with drugs okay I had
the opposite I feel like maybe it's
because I came in contact with so many
men I used to work at the mall but like
it was all dry lips like to the point
where we had to peel you have to we have
to take out like a one of those brow
lines a spoolie yeah rub their lips
we'll see I do that you got to exfoliate
your lips this is a part of hygiene that
people are leaving out right you got a
scrub under your arms you have to brush
your tongue and you have to exfoliate
your lips because you have too much dead
skin on it you the lip balm and or it's
not gonna absorb any way we're major
self-care lapse in the mouth area there
was also a couple people on this set
that if I talk about it I'm really
worried I'm gonna actually throw up is
that like line of shmegmer that you get
around the lips it's like a the dead
skin and spit it's like a clam chowder
like a like a hard come line right
across the lip that goes all the way
around and then like how do you not know
that's there how do you not feel that
line of funk on your mouth it's like
they suck the skin off a sardine so
gross and then I'm literally gagging
that when it gets in the corners of
someone's mouth and it's like these cob
like it's like peeling when they talk
like with it if they put the lipstick on
over I go and they're talking like just
pink like baby pink like magma on either
side of the corners of you have to check
in when you go to the bathroom you look
in the mirror that's why the mirrors
there to check to see if you have
crystallized come on your mouth in a
business environment oh you guys died so
happens to me sometimes and is it just
because I think it's when I use like a
lip gloss that's two visits lip product
and it's grabbing your dead skin and
piling up this can't get past that area
so you're telling me that that white
line that's around people's lip is oh my
god I'm gagging dead skin like congealed
around your yeah as soon as it's food if
people like it okay okay now you just
now we have to i'm officially too too
disgusted my producers are looking
anxious is everything okay I feel okay
everybody feel good they're also married
I never know if they're fighting or if
this is just like a marital resentment
or if something's going wrong or if
there's a fight from last night spilling
over begin of hygiene you were talking
about thing good segue but well I would
just think about this you wouldn't think
people need to do do you wash your legs
okay well I'm not doing this why this is
like a big thing on Twitter I feel like
what I've seen a lot of like women don't
wash their legs thing i expel I've never
seen that but I just wanted you know a
know yeah i exfoliate my legs do you
thought Irish no I use like those mitts
that you that I that are from Korea and
they're like an exfoliating mitts and a
glove and I wash my whole body I'm big
on exfoliating my friend just said they
don't do that and I just want to know if
you did huh yeah no I mean look
sometimes I'm in the bath I'm gonna be
honest with you sometimes I'm lazy or
about it than others you know I wouldn't
like eat off I wouldn't eat an egg off
my leg if I think what am i fucking dr.
Seuss now yeah I know I just I we try to
think of a food that you would and it
just happened to rhyme I didn't do that
on purpose but anyway I'm really just I
would like it's the holiday season I
would like to remind everyone exfoliate
your lips you can do it with a brush I
do with a toothbrush actually just
exfoliate your lips put on some lotion
or balm don't get the lip balms that
have the addicted stuff in it a lot of
them are addictive lip balms right yeah
I heard once that some of them have true
science with Benton right yeah I don't
I'm not a journalist I'm not looking at
facts these are just high feel emotional
science yeah I heard once that some lip
products are addictive because they have
um what's this stuff in drywall a little
piece of glass fiber glass fiber glass
yeah fiberglass net cultural event in
doing construction how does a show I
would keeps them
that's just like shut up so they keep
getting drunk would it be in the
ingredients I plan it called it they
probably call it something else
yeah good a lip scrub yeah no honestly
I'm actually to fight you on that you
don't need a lip scrub that is a but
that is a product that is that you can
just use a towel you can use a washcloth
and you can use a toothbrush there you
can this is not an elitist but expensive
process Benton likes to use rollers not
here
kitchen he wants use like a sixteen
dollar sugar scrub whose foliate is
perfect pillowy luminous lips just use a
fucking old toothbrush it works get the
shmegmer off your face this is cream so
your go-to is to use your toothbrush get
your dead skin and food off your mouth
then brush your teeth with it let's go
to five million a day we shed each
person wow that's wild
five million skin cells a day and
estimate they just go onto the carpet
and stuff there's everywhere nor in dust
dust yeah I'm allergic to dust it's cuz
I'm our new tenant yeah I had to take
all the carpets out of my house once
because I would get really bad under-eye
bags like I had these horrible under-eye
bags and I went all over to every
Hollywood doctor on the planet to be
like what am I gonna do with my eye bags
and they were all like we need to put
like whatever pig feed in there whatever
shit that they put in people's face now
like a filler and I was like I don't
want it look filler I don't look crazy
I'm look crazy and they agreed they were
like your face will look crazy if we put
anything and but this one doctor finally
didn't try to put needles in my face he
was like you have allergies do an
allergy test went and did an allergy
test and out of you know this movie knew
an allergy test they put like words of
needles needles they literally put like
200 needles in you and where it turns
red that's where they say give the
allergy and I'm I was just got like
don't you think I could possibly be
allergic to needles
maybe it's red because it's a fucking
needle like it seems like a pretty
sketchy system but I was really lured to
dust took all the carpets out of my
house and then I stopped having such bad
under-eye bags I love that that that's
such a Whitney story you look in the end
of all my carpets out because I'm an
extremist I know I used to have 18 years
really for what allergies oh I'm
allergic to everything really thing but
goldfish they said I had the piece of
paper that says allergic to gold that's
what I always thought you're allergic to
everything except pretty much yeah cow
dander every weed does I'm allergic to
mole everyone's allergic to mold but I'm
so bad allergic that there was mold in
my middle school and I had to literally
stop going to school for a while until
they got the mold on the ceiling
wherever it was fixed well and what
happens to you when you're around mold
oh it's I'd get like deathly you know
there's your food I'm allergic to eggs
milk still yeah but not as bad
everyone's kind of alerted to milk yes
we shouldn't be drinking mom it's
absolutely the older I got the they're
not as bad like I can TX but if I eat
like too many eggs it's like I get like
itchy and greif Oh gross
uh-huh so did you grow out of your
allergies or I mean though just how it's
helped a lot obviously like I used to
not be able to be around like cats any
kind of animals and now I can yeah cat I
used to be really allergic to cats like
if they scratched me I'd be like crazy
icky and I used to like my eyes if they
scratched you yeah with all the bacteria
in their claws that make sense oh so I
guess everyone's allergic to a cat
scratch okay that makes a lot of sense
but I would get my eyes would get all
puffy but now I think I'm good with cats
yeah I beat it I was allergic at sand I
beat it you probably grew out of it I
used to have a go-kart that I would
drive through our farm and through like
that like what is it it's like cat grass
that tall grasses and field that nip no
it's like I don't we call it cat grass
don't know what it is but I would drive
through it and I remember like my dad
was like okay
stop here when I stopped my eyes were
swelled shut yeah I were allergic to a
lot of like things there was a tree in
my old house that they said I was
allergic to but I'm not gonna cut down a
fucking tree began too much of a pussy
to be able to tolerate the shit coming I
feel urge to magnolia trees you have one
New York yeah that's your fault if you
know if you're alert what there's no
biological purpose for being allergic to
a beautiful tree like what in your
ancestry made that happen we don't want
to live by them I need to stop talking
but sorry dude sometimes my braid this
it's doing a podcast is weird because
that you don't have a second to just
think you know like you have to be so
prepared at all times and I like to
think and be thoughtful believe it or
not but we do have an amazing guest
today we are going to get to him now his
name is mr. Jim Jeffries such a big fan
very excited I'm excited I'm a little
nervous because there's so much I want
to talk to him about and usually you
don't want to talk a lot so no I just I
try to keep the interviews to less than
two hours
and I'm a lot to ask him but I feel like
what I need to just go is okay I'm doing
this podcast this is happening I can
always have informed too you know now
just like just don't rush through it
because I did find with a couple guests
I was like so bad they wanted to get to
other questions and other topics and so
many people were writing in
with questions that I ended up
truncating the conversation a little bit
and I'd rather just do a couple topics
really well
then a lot of topics you know yeah just
ask to talk let them talk yeah because
all the guests that have been on already
like one guy come back let's do a part
you know so we'll just have them next
time if I don't get to it all because I
write these lists of things that I want
to ask about and I just don't want to
force it that's it you are very thorough
it's really nice that's just a mental
note to myself but also if you want to
make your podcast three hours long once
you sure can
yeah it's yours that's a good point
you're welcome I forget I'm just so used
to coming from network television where
it's like you have to like do everything
has to be a certain amount of time and
everything's got to be tight and snappy
and everything's got to be like
perfectly lit like I just this is so
it's like too good to be true yeah you
can just do everyone here and then go
edit that I did that cut that and I do
trust me and some people in the comments
don't like it oh very few I like the
idea that it that if people don't like
that I make edits in the podcast like we
want this to be sloppier this will be it
it would just be a spilling I don't know
should we talk about that this is all
I'm editing out I'm editing what I'm
like huh hmm like I'm attending myself
thinking those are the main things that
I had that or slurring or saying
something that's gonna have me canceled
okay Jim Jefferies is he Wow all right I
hate what I say that because there's
some kind of implication that I'll be a
completely different person yeah yeah do
you not I mean let me know when we're
rolling so I know one to have a good
personality that's why I've never wanted
to do a reality show that's like we have
film 24 hours a day I just know I could
be edited badly and I could I could be a
disaster in that type of environment I
don't I I wouldn't want to because I
think I'm very insecure because I'm not
that funny a person when I mean you're
pretty funny you thank you for you chat
to you I just mean like I don't try to
be funny when I'm not performing yeah I
get that cuz I'm tired yeah you know
yeah like I just wouldn't want people
saying like my bathroom ready I'm not
like shitting myself but just that just
the lack of cleaning I do shitting
yourself no yeah you are shitting
yourself as I guess I do yeah yeah know
what I'm shitting me so yeah I guess it
might one of my best friends is in in
the the Jay
right now for the British I'm a
celebrity get me out yes I've been
trying to watch that online yeah looks
like hell would you ever do that no I've
been asked to do shows like that I've
been asked to the Australian versions of
shows like that but I wouldn't know
there's no way all those shows now they
just they just be effective but 24 hours
a day eating bugs and shit I don't want
to eat bugs yeah it is sort of this
signing up to humiliate yourself where I
love that they always assume comedians
would be super down for that well he's
in there he's in there with Caitlyn
Jenner oh wow right and she did it for
for 500,000 pounds which is a lot of
money I'm not saying it's not for a
Jenner just go to your daughter and just
count down with any bugs this week throw
me a meal that's like 800,000 America
that's almost a million dollars but
after taxes after paying your age and
your manager probably ends up being you
get about 35 cents on the dollar right
there playing for it then PR and what
type of stuff so for Caitlyn Jenner
that's like I'm sure Caitlyn Jenner does
like appearances gets paid like that to
me very much feels like she's basically
doing it for free
I think everyone gets out of there and I
lose a bit of white though so maybe
everyone looks at dancing this does
everyone says that one excuse but then
she says what did you do why you wanted
attention I don't know I just I could
never do something like that I like to
embarrass myself in private I bet just
before I got my HBO special I was I was
living in Britain I was doing okay as
doing like small sort of 600 seat room
it is and stuff and then I came over to
America and I thought my career was
going nowhere and I did accept the job
being on Celebrity boot camp what is
that it's a show that didn't go it would
have been me a few boy band members and
an ex actually and it's just like being
called a maggot by a drill sergeant and
having to run up and down hills and
vomit and I was at that stage I was like
all right this is what I'm gonna do Tom
Green went into that world bridges when
are they Celebrity Big Brother and I'll
do
or the The Apprentice while to me but
Tom green that makes sense when I look
at someone like you it's like Oh someone
who's really smart and really incisive
now I want to see him exercise yeah yeah
why do you also have to see us exercise
in humility like where we have gone we
now want to see people we respect and
admire just be miserable is that's
something like when you watch the
Celebrity Apprentice you used to see
people with big stars that were on there
like there might be a big star anymore
yeah watching Cyndi Lauper's she was
massive but I know what that stuff well
I mean I think that I've been in this
business long enough to know that it's
like okay that / how is that person
making money now you know that is
probably a paycheck saying did they
still meet that's only this Caitlyn
Jenner still need to I think Caitlyn
Jenner doesn't but I think Cyndi Lauper
I don't know I think people just get
bored of not being famous
that's don't you ever think about
retiring no I do know I'm a workaholic
I've never oh I've been working like
these I always think like because people
he's got what would you do I think I'd
be alright with nothing but I've never
given nothing and go I'd be worried
about you if you stopped working
I could I could abuse substances pretty
quickly I just you and I mean I this way
I think yeah you would be like who
remember when that Eddie furlong that
guy that was in Terminator that
celebrity all of a sudden there was a
story American history there was a story
that he like stole a bunch of lobsters
from a restaurant like that would be us
yeah that's to have expensive tastes but
you've been out of money see still below
I feel like we would like start
shoplifting so alright we would need the
adrenaline rush I have I have my credit
card I'm stalling I had that whole like
text did you make a payment here did you
make a payment Wow
and so I rang up the bank and the the
two payments were one was for baby
formula and the other one was to get a
car out of an impound and I was like and
it was like an Akron Ohio and I was like
yeah I made those payments I just can
tell by the transactions how sad this
story was and I was like I let him use
it for like like a wake and I can look
at you and and then it was like they
kept on buying too many shoes on razzle
bath or whatever it Razzles the the
discount
someone else's money ways to kind of
razzle they still got a discount she
lowers your self-esteem you're not even
gonna go very clear you haven't been
caught yet and it we can catch you
pretty quickly the cars from the impound
there has to be a paper trail there that
leads this is someone who probably stole
your credit card but also is kind of a
fan and is like I don't want to I don't
want to go to Macy's I like this guy
want to be a dead um you know I just had
another one the other day like someone I
was paying a bill for Sprint and we're
not I don't have Sprint I'm not doing
this so what's we gotta tighten up your
security with I got a new credit card
coming and they've already cancelled
that one and you know buy a lot of stuff
online i buy most of my things online I
have a brother who works in in retail
and he's just like and he used of
developed shopping centers yeah and he
says that that's like the worst thing in
the world it's like when we talk about
people illegally downloading things like
it's ruining company people having
cameras in there for in there in the
audience
gathering and he goes did you buy this
online I want you just kick me and my
family out on the streets because he's
all about the malls but you can't stop
this time but they're taking there it's
starting to circle back it seems like
because now there's Amazon stores have
you seen the Amazon stores in Amazon so
I've heard about the Amazon stores yeah
so it's like now we went online to now
develop the store which is the spin-off
of it's better with clothes I'm so lazy
that if I buy something and it doesn't
fit but then I just find some clothes
that I've never wrapped him back up and
sent and it I said him back this is a
while thing I ordered something off of
Amazon like a candle and it came already
burned it was like a fake because
there's a lot of vendors on there that
are fake right you've gotten you saw
this it was like an expensive candle
that came already burned in like a
shitty box and it was like well I'm not
gonna fucking hurt you kind of have me
by the balls here because I'm not gonna
return it looks like you know about it
yeah yeah it was like no one's gonna
believe me anyway it's gonna seem like
I'm lying it's not even worth it I'm a
big fan of when I get the wrong thing in
a restaurant I have a couple of
mouthfuls and go oh this is the wrong
thing and then I have four more
mouthfuls before I order you know I
think and then I go I had that I did I
did it the other day with something like
I wanted something like past that I had
like Cajun sauce in it yeah
and it
like lemon butter and a my 11-part is
not Cajun but I still wasn't sure to
begin with because I'm a moron so um Jim
yes are we friends
I believe we're friend I think we are we
are we don't hang out that much but we
have each other's numbers we text
occasion yeah we complement each other
in social media if one of us has
achieved something that's true so that's
friends like I feel like you know you're
somebody that I I think we're both kind
of lone wolf type people
yeah or am i right I don't really hang
in the comedy club yeah I'm gonna be God
for that I wasn't my 20s yeah now I'm
just know that I don't get along with
people no you do just I just don't know
what you get out of it like there's a
lot of people that the same cut like
like yo your buddy D'Elia he's there
every every night that's his that's what
he likes yeah I think Rogen's always
hanging out at the club got nothing
against people doing that it's just not
you know I think maybe for me
I changed with having a kid I just I
became like you know I just this morning
I did a school run and I was thinking to
myself this is kind of knock like four
years off my life the school run but I
hate driving and dropping artists you
have to wake up at 6:30 and then you're
still a comic at night yeah I got six
thirty because he has to get the bus at
7:25 and you're like that's a fucking
kind of a job that he's sorry for this
way yeah no I mean that's what yeah no
ever of women do it every day all right
and then like I know I'm not doing the
best job with it either like I know as
long as he here's my thing I'm sick of
this like good parent bad parent if he
gets to the bus and if he's in school
you're a good - he's playing yes right
and he's got and he's hair's not done
dad has like fluffy hair Rob when kids
look like Krusty the Klown kids
shouldn't have perfectly quaffed hair
like a creepy little I had one time I
couldn't get him dressed like a go in
get dressed on so I was tough anyway he
had swimming or something that day and
it turns out that he on his own he was
six at the time but he and he's oh he
forgot to put underwear on
I don't think you could do that anymore
and then the school rings me up tell me
about the underwear policy like I'm
meant to go oh I thought we were I
didn't know I didn't know of course it
was just an era it was just an era that
he didn't have underwear but I like they
act like this was a manipulative thing
that I did and I went why did you put
your underwear off god I've got to
remind him in the morning I'm like eat
some Coco Pops or some and rice bubbles
or they look like ice cream eating rice
krispies I'm here right and then I got
eight dead or ice cameras I go
have you eaten your breakfast and then
cuz I'm upstairs getting myself ready
yeah and then he's like oh I forgot I
forgot that if you bet you underwear on
I do today I do I have under way I also
have questions how did the teacher know
he wasn't wearing underwear
what were you because he had to change
for swimming why were they watching I
don't know I think you need to ask more
questions I think or maybe I forgot to
send him in his pack these swimmers
there's probably different layers of
things missing pieces of this because
he's mother rang me up and she was
really angry with me like wadding you
put underwear on him and of course my
intention is always to have him in
underwear yeah I always want that yes he
wasn't wearing it this was not something
that his mother reckons that he has a
shower every day and I just when I was a
kid I reckon it's three times a week
when you're a little kid because you
don't stink like you do now that's
correct that's great don't sweat I think
just covering yourself in soap
constantly it doesn't system kids need
to be drinking water from the tap they
need to be in the sandbox they need to
be getting dirty or else they're sick
all the time people I know that are like
pure Elling their kids constantly their
kids always sick yeah I know I don't I
don't care for he's a hygiene well-being
just baby wipe that shit that's why
they're called baby wipes I keep it
clean his house and you know he's no
he's fine I'm sure you think you don't
want to develop a bad association with
her you know if you're forcing your kid
to wash themselves every day aren't
thinking I'm not I just well I just
think three times like after we play
sport guys that like three times a week
and
I don't know was a kid a box all right
it was just bath night yeah was Friday
and then your hand wet and then you
combed it down into a perfect part and
you put a dressing gown on and you sat
out and you watch the a-team or whatever
it is and then you didn't do it again -
yeah every Friday we wash ourselves and
then there's something around 18 years
we were like okay I probably should wash
all the time yeah I remember I hate
about so much as a kid because I had
seen that what was the thing where the
blob the scary stories not Tales from
the Crypt was it I had watched Tales
from the Crypt or one of those shows and
there was a lake where there was a blob
that all the girls jumped in and got
eaten by the blob but could not I could
not take a shower or bath you just
assumed that happen correct I have
strange memories of bathing with my
brothers for too long would like like to
all deny age like I was like I was like
seven but they were like twelve I
remember my brother used we were in the
shower he'd make me sit on top of the
drainpipe we'd see if we could flood the
room like that's not you can't be
cleaner doing that I remember I was so
scared of taking bath that I would turn
the bath on and put my hand pretend I
was taking a bath and tell my parents I
had taken one when I hadn't I would say
you would make splashing noise yeah I
would just be like sit in there and
pretend I was taking one my mother my
mother who I had a very we argued a lot
she passed away six months ago but we
argued a lot me mama and the first time
I ever went back to Australia to do gigs
and I've been doing all right at the the
thing but there was the cine comedy
store had a Booker and I don't know the
Booker particularly liked me I was maybe
23 24 but I see she rang up to ask for a
gig right this is back before I had a
mobile phone so all that was it was in
the house was my parents number and my
mum got overly excited that there that
this comedy store had run and she walks
in and I'm having a shower I'm 23 I'm
completely I get remote comes Dean and
goes Jim Jim there's someone on the
phone for you and I assume it has to be
one of my friends cause who else has the
number I'm in the fucking shower
do you jerk off in the shower that I
wasn't jigging it but I'm like it I'm
yelling at my woman get the fuck out of
the room like that right so now this
Comedy Store Booker who didn't already
like me just thinks I'm abusive to my
mother but I was I was well within my
rights to do this and I had to yeah I
apologize but at what age can mom stop
looking at their naked moanin and what
age do fathers need to stop looking at
naked oh that's okay I think I just
don't know I think we sons I think it's
sort of around nine and they can't keep
doing the whole I I've seen it all
before I used to change you yeah that
doesn't think dads and daughters would
be a similar thing it's before any sign
of puberty comes in yeah you have to get
up
any sign of difference starts working in
or before my sons just recently
discovered he's dig like I got a lot of
kids do it touching it all the time but
he's getting more curious about his dick
all of a sudden and what do you do about
telling him maybe not to do it in public
without giving a complex like what's one
of the rules around him touching his
dick well it's just I don't he's not
doing any in public yet he's okay he's
wise enough not not to do it in public
but if he doesn't public do you say hey
that's the thing we do in private what's
that conversation um yeah you say that
you don't pull it out or don't talk
about it all was very tricky not to you
know I'm so fearful of my all the
footage of me saying horrible things
online I don't know see my niece my
niece is maybe 14 and she was on social
media and she said about some Australian
TV host when blah blah blah is a cunt is
what she wrote right and I'm like 14 now
I say I'm like synonymous with the word
but I'm like have to write to her hey
what are you doing you don't do that
you know because I've got a parent he
honor and she's like really you don't do
it unless it makes you millions of
dollars exactly and that was the whole
thing yeah how can you know so anyways
it's a job it's a different thing don't
cut into people on the street unless
you're a surgeon
you're getting paid to do it they cut
into people in it so a surgeon telling
their niece aneesa's like stabbing
someone you say I do that but under very
different surgeons the first the first
surgical procedure they have to tell the
person no there would be no surgeries
ever surgery would have been cancelled
I would imagine but I think that because
teaching hospitals they do it on
cadavers a bunch first oh no no look you
want a heart that been through the same
year many times yeah before they fly
them no I don't think legally they would
have to tell you mm-hmm no I hate it
when comedians do that like every now
and then when you're like at a sort of
random venue in a random place and I was
like this is my first time doing
stand-up I tell them that case it was so
okay so let's do another one so it's
what a pilot ever say hey guys my first
time doing this flying other missions
normally they're ex-military or they've
had many many hours of flight time also
the planes that is self flying all they
got to do is take off and land having an
open and then the machines winning and
then I'd be like Oh have it going great
but like okay so next case so so
transsexual huh do they have to tell you
before they had sex the other sex they
used to be I think it's up to them I
think you definitely have to say before
marriage that's that sounds unfair I
think that one's better cuz it could be
kids involved
yeah it's evolving you don't have the
reproductive thing going also if yeah if
it hasn't come up at that point and that
person has it felt safe enough to talk
to you about it that sounds like yeah
thing also if you've gotten all the way
to marriage and they haven't shown you
any photos from their child there's a
lot of problems with this story you're
getting married too soon yeah you ever
met the parents the parents have been
chipped in on that it's a little too
much but let me ask you about being a
parent what annoys you the most about
other parents because you probably have
to go to school function yeah mmm yeah
there's a lot of there's a lot of
different I don't like the parents that
with the overachieving kids yeah baby
shit I mean like yeah
I feel like they're all going to be able
to tie their shoelaces and like this
whole like my ones doing it at - yeah
it's like I go get it I just don't feel
like there's like parents who really the
helicopter parents but the ones that
really hound their kids where like I
went to you know to a fun park with a
with another family and it's like okay
so we're gonna be on the ride in ten
seconds the kids like three can you
count down from ten now in Spanish right
and you're like and then me and Hank
could just like look gotta be fast I was
reading this article about how because
women that were in the workforce and you
know lawyers and CEOs and shit are now
raising their kids but they have this
type a mentality of now that they're
raising their kids like running a
business
we had an Hanks birthday party at the
party I had two kids doing homework now
off to the side nerd now we're learning
I had a rare dolphin to the side now no
no no no we're all gonna jump on this
bouncy castle no I'm gonna eat chocolate
you know I mean yeah what are you doing
man this is when the kids having plays
is their only chance to be a fucking kid
yeah I just think it's really I don't
know about the whole going through the
universe you know I you know I did it
very briefly yeah I just don't know if
if everyone goes that it means nothing
yeah and now it feels like everyone goes
my schools like 90% of the kids go to
college and graduate and you're like
well what's the point of that we're all
ending the workforce in the same like no
one cares if you have a degree say I
don't know if education is where it like
you know everything you need to knows on
your phone you got if it's true that's
the problem is about history books
really who had documented any of this
well when I was a kid the common belief
in Australian schools this is what we
were taught this was in the curriculum
the way the dinosaurs died was they ate
all the food they over grazed there was
no food yet so the carnivores though the
herbivores ate all the food and then the
carnivores ate all the herbivores and
now there's no pause there
all done yeah and then it was meteor we
didn't even have a meteor than the
meteorite kind yeah and then that in the
80s I think people started going oh this
might be something new revised science
we were just talking about this yeah
just got taught that and then like Pluto
was a planet Pluto wasn't a planet
Pluto's a planet again
and then when I think when I was a kid
the Milky Way was the only galaxy like
we hadn't even yeah we hadn't even
figured out that there was other
galaxies right and like like when my dad
was a kid he was learning at school that
homosexuality was a mental illness oh
geez yeah that was science that was
sorry that was real science and so you
learn these things and then that carries
through with you and then you just we're
all idiots yeah the most progressive
self-righteous people the most woke
people right now and 50 years we'll be
ignorant racists and I cannot fucking
wait yeah it's kinda it's gonna be very
like the eggs are bad eggs it good and
we had a food pyramid milk was like the
healthiest thing you found on milk was
second milk milk and milk and butter was
second and eggs
the second eggs are still good but down
the bottom was just bread and pasta
loaves of bread and my pile of rice it
was like loaves of bread and then I
think was fruit and vegetable then it
was like dairy there was like there was
like meat and then there's like oil
things you're not supposed to eat are
you the pyramid is what wrong way around
completely there were no vegetables
there was no Cape fruits are no fruit
and vegies my Maddy like second or third
yeah it definitely was I don't know can
we pull it up for one yeah let's boot
pyramid from the 90s from the naughty
which is now everything that give now
it's the cancer pyramid basically yeah
there's a lot of refined things yeah
bread was a very big one there we go
what's this oh my gosh look at the
colors
huh no fruit and veggies still down the
button now but we have to look at one
from the 80s because I'm sure this is a
movie one bit that ones that you know
the one with the braid that one they
just picked on they older than you where
it's at old and new yeah oh yeah 1980s
yeah yeah for those of you listening
we're pointing to a screen franticly
pyramid yeah all in ooh ah there we go
so down the bottom
my god bread and pasta
oh and potato pie out of place that's
just two sandwiches this is wild and
then look there's a yeah the white bread
on the bottom and then the whole gray
and is that a can of mayonnaise on the
second tier that Canada on the third
that's just a glass of milk and some
cheese slices and a Yoplait or like a
yogurt is strawberry flavored yolk and
then lean meats everything that clogs
your arteries and then wait there's a
plate of butter that's so funny this is
the cancer pyramid yeah and now a bread
bread still just even today breads
rocking out in the second one it's a lot
of rubbish this is my and then also
juice which is people think juice is
healthy it's just pure sugar you might
as well just have a soda pop if it's
from cons I mean depends on where you
get it a lot of it like frozen sugar
garlic right pulp you I yeah it just
feels clunky in your mouth I like pulp
it makes me think it's actually coming
from something natural my favorite
beverage on earth is a Slurpee look at
it drink Slurpees all day but the
problem is they over syrup um oh that's
the problem too much I like the
consistency of a Slurpee but I got half
syrup in there okay I'm sure you can do
though I guess you can you can people at
7-eleven they already run what's going
on there I like it when people get
successful and then they get something
in their house that's really important
to them like you know every celebrity
you go to their house and they've like a
ping-pong machine or like a weird sex
doll like I like that you're the guy
that like has a Slurpee machine
I got a few pinball machines was the
first thing I did I saw that I bought
pinball machines
I like those I had one I had one in my
office at the show mm-hmm but I have
room for a fifth one so I gave it away
to somebody hey you don't strike me
someone who would like pinball cuz
there's no merit or justice and why
you're good at it
oh there is true there's definitely a
game of skill you gotta know when to
freakin up the paddles you gotta break
the Machine the points I feel like it's
just chaos no that's just kind of you as
president I don't think of Rorschach
test it's a very
there's a lot of skill in pinball like
the top prize in the world always win
the World Championships always always
always Lyman sheats always wins all the
time that's why it's yeah and you have
what I think you're four of them I say
four of them III I entered a world
championship pinball tournament I got
down to like a final 20 really yeah and
there's like 400 play but then I got
paid back and is that something that you
liked as a kid or something I did liked
it in the 90s I got really into it yeah
yeah is that your thing like is that
what you spend money on the ones that
get like 10 grand a machine yeah but
then you try them in and out and so I
buy the occasional watch but I'm not
like I don't
apart from that I like to have a nice
car yeah but apart from that I don't
really I don't really know what to spend
money on guys don't have a lot of things
you guys have watches you can't really
wear a jewelry girl shoes and watches
are the only real socially acceptable
thing to spend yeah and even then we
should like like when we're doing the
Jim Jeffrey show they kept on giving me
shoes each week so yeah too many shoes
now yeah I'm never gonna wear them again
what makes you happy that you spend
money I'm like what works I like food
really expensive yeah there's only two
types of food in my in my opinion
there's like Michelin star level food
and then there's hot dogs or hamburgers
they expect I can't like like like
probably the man can fit anyone guys all
the portions when you can't imagine none
of the good restaurants when you go to
fucking Cheesecake Factory
yeah the portions are messy I mean that
type of food anything in between its
restaurant II I don't like but I high
and low end I can eat in and out every
day I love that shit what nothing seems
to scare you what do you mean nothing
seems gonna cry vibe in here yeah sure
sure what do you what are you not scared
you're not scared of anything I'm just
going to use this vape that is in the
news everyday is that did that scare you
- gave me because I know I in my heart
of hearts think it's nowhere near as bad
as smoking because I know what smoking
feels like I know but I find it when
people are like it's not as bad at
smoking I'm like that's still not saying
much
no no no but it's gonna be a stepping
stone to get enough Ivan yeah really is
no I mean at a cigarette in a very very
long time that's really impressive
that's it I also think that these it's
really about those backyard vitamin D
one yeah it's the dodgy ones in the
places that aren't you know and also
like once they're 20 something dates
from smoking yeah well I mean I mean
also driving your car is one of the most
dangerous it's just another thing to
shine people about their addiction yes
but if those are just like I love that
like when that something takes over the
new cycle like that and it's still not
like we don't have health care for
people that are just dying of cancer I
always hated like in Britain they always
used to go
the average smoke across the NHS the
National Health Service right because
there one gets pretty health care there
there's blowing some people's mind
health care here I have to live here and
I my sign is on my health care and other
stuff and I still pay for my ex's health
care and and so what happens here is you
all believe that you get better health
care because it's private or something
like that but it's like climbing it it's
very hard yeah I'm a socialist when it
comes to health care when it comes to
health care I grow I grew up in a
socialist country with the health care
and I lived in Britain in Britain I once
had a fractured skull after I was in a
comedy club and someone came up
afterwards it smashed my head into a
table from behind that's different than
the one that the guy that rambles you
know the guy that punched me this is a
couple years before that right and so I
had a little crack in that my skull
between my eyes and I worked was
concussed and and then I woke up in a
hospital and then they were that now now
Jim Joe I use my middle name instead of
my last name for a stage they way they
didn't even check my real name then
check my license I was in there for six
days and in the end I just walked out
they didn't even check or anything like
that they the government never took a
cent of me then the government gave me
$10,000 victim of crime payer 10,000
pound victim a crime payer Jesus and I'm
here and I wasn't a citizen I wasn't a
citizen and that's wild and sorry that
would happen to a tourist every day ya
know that's why I asked you because I
know when I went to last time I went to
London the three cab drivers that I was
with
they all went are you coming over here
to get use our health care and I was
like no dude yeah yeah a lot of people a
lot of women go over there to give birth
well that's the thing is I always get
picked on so what happens is every every
year in Britain they have adverts that
go the NHS smokers cost the NHS during
their lifetime fifty thousand pounds
although the average about 20,000 pounds
alright and then it's like you do the
maths the average smoker pays about 60
13 tackiness yeah on their cigarettes so
those smokers are keeping the pace of
flow and all that money goes to health
care yeah they they're buying their
cancer mm-hmm yeah don't fucking get
into him you're just jealous cuz they're
rich Simon's alcoholics they're paying
for their whatever liver disease or
whatever they're doing yeah you don't
tax heroin or cocaine or whatever yeah
I'm sure the whole weight thing now very
interested by far I've gotten into I
hardly drink anymore and I've gotten
well into edibles yeah yeah been a big
change in my life because I never really
was into it I used to get paranoid on it
and then I just had to fight what do you
do do you do this achiever the indica do
you have like I do either either if I do
IndyCar if I want to chill on the couch
the couch yeah and if I want to if I
want to be up and about yeah use this at
Ava and then sometimes they use the hard
one I got me so early like ten to
fifteen milligrams yeah hi hi do you not
feel like your brain is less sharp I
mean I owe ya but I'd never perform on
yeah I always feel like I'm a little bit
groggy but I think I'm sharper when I'm
drunk like in the sense that I'm you
don't have an inhibition so I have a
filter maybe a much sharper but I'm you
say I need to go to a break okay we all
want to do the right thing to keep our
bodies healthy in the long run but even
if we try really hard to eat kale salads
and drink green smoothies it's a
freaking nightmare it's impossible and
we're still most likely not getting all
of the essential nutrients we need on a
daily basis and I think that's why I'm
holding not even joking enter ritual the
obsessively researched vitamin for women
rituals essentials have the nutrients
most of us do not get enough from food
it's fun a nightmare they have it in
clean absorbable forms and no shady
additives or ingredients that can do
more harm than but you know some
vitamins have chemicals in them that are
bad for you and food coloring I did not
know that I did but when I did know is
that these diamonds are real good and
they are for women but sometimes S&E can
take care of charging you for those hit
my cash app to easy to take capsules
provide nine nutrients you need to
support a strong foundation for your
health and that's probably why your
breath is so freakin good because they
have a little mint inside so that your
you don't have fish burps yeah I have
good breath nice bosom spasm first of
all pronounce it right better health
does not happen overnight right now
ritual is offering my listeners 10% off
your first three months that is a big
deal fill in the gaps in your diet with
essential for women a small step that
helps support a healthy foundation for
your body ritual comm slash Whitney to
start your ritual today that's 10% off
during your first three months at ritual
comm slash what you do I get a discount
if I buy them you should three months of
health sign me up
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist that is
unbelievable I need it Add to Cart
you can start communicating in under 24
hours I'm real I know that's measured
anybody will talk to me the service is
available worldwide you can log into
your account anytime and send a message
to your counselor you get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
I need this I mean not as much as you
think I do but I need it better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if needed
that is meses steel have you ever tried
to fire a therapist no you need a hire
counselor just to be able to get away
from another counselor this is way
easier a social worker I hate it so many
things it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and as
financial aid is even available Wow
better health wants you to start living
a happier life today visit their website
and read their testimonials they're
posted daily and you also with better
help if you're getting therapy online
you have to go to their creepy waiting
rooms of therapists and see their like
yoga monthly magazine and all the weird
asshole little tests there's always like
a test too much help there there's
always like toys no games they want to
see what toy you pick up you know the
thing that's like a bunch of magnet
balls and they could think think think
those are always there those yeah that
says some about you
so visitor better help calm slash
Whitney that's better help and join over
500,000 people taking charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional special offer
for good for you listeners get 10% off
your first month a better help calm
slash Whitney
but now we're back it's you're gonna
have a podcast I'm gonna do pocket I'm
gonna do a podcast called uh I don't
know about that
and so I this is the theory of my
podcast right let's go about that then
it'll be me my friend forest and we
reproduce
I love forest so much guy so fucking
funny funny a nice hard combination to
find and say so what's gonna happen is
they're gonna bring up a topic and I'm
gonna be that guy in a bar that even if
he doesn't know what he's talking about
he's gonna have a go something as simple
as I can be prepared at all I would be
very like like tell us everything you
know about Plato when it was invented
invented it well I think bummer and so
you have a guy but another episode might
be slavery that was everything you know
like like we all know it happens but I
can't give you but I love I love when
slavery comes up with people in bars
because there's always that one person
who's like you know white people were
enslaved to right scotch-irish were
slain and then and then you have I want
the original slides to the Jews and
you're like yeah we're not talking about
you know want to talk about the Native
American Indians the slave to get all
the PR and you're like okay there's
always one person that wants to change
your view on slavery who's been bottling
it up yeah there's one person who really
wants to talk about white slavery which
was actually called indentured servitude
and they really want to like change the
focus to the white slaves so it's gonna
be just me having a go and then you
don't really need guess but if let's say
I have it you wanna on the show we could
pick a subject you know everything about
yeah oh that's a great idea
that's such a great idea it's like Oh
breakups yeah it's like it's like I
don't know is mastermind where you can
have your specialty topic yeah I don't
know yeah they're charming here master
way I I mean I've it's like it's like
it's like playing jeopardy but one of
the topics you're a genius on where you
know I could do that I could hear the
Beatles from 1962 to 1966 would be my
category that's a really good run cuz
it's also fun to watch someone that
actually knows the answer have to suffer
through people have no idea what they're
done there's like people who think they
knew everything like oh I didn't know
well that's everyone all the time
but I yeah I want to do another podcast
that is me solve
crimes just by getting a little bit of
information cuz I think that a lot of
times we try too hard to solve crimes
with like facts I know that sounds
insane but if you just use your human
nature got it like oh yeah well this is
what that person would do well I'm not
good with those documentaries because I
agree with who of his last interview I'm
such a moron I'm like they're like
watching a murder auditioning actors
like when you do TV shows the last
person comes any like well that's the
person that you do it then another
person did you watch that one the the
neighbor is about the guy who is the
last Nazi that was getting caught and
he's gonna be Ivan the Terrible you know
he got his new one on Netflix he's got
it lived in Cleveland huh and he lived
in Cleveland and he and I've been Bink
you know something he second name he was
like a Polish guy and he was working at
the Ford plant and then like he had a
family and he was happy and been living
in America since 1945 and it turned out
he might have been one of the Nazis
nastiest Nazis in the classiest Nazis
yeah he was a big Nazi he was even
behave about he was Ivan the Terrible
which is like it is one concentration
camp he was just poking kids in with a
sword right but now everyone's like this
guys like it when the plant was like
he's the nicest guy like this right and
so there was a lot of debate with it and
then you find out he wasn't a Nazi but
maybe he wasn't that Nazi and then I'm
like there was bits where I'm like I'll
leave him alone he's led a good life and
then you hear some things all that is
bad he should go away the idea that he
wasn't as bad a Nazi it's just like how
quickly we lower our bar they like he
was a Nazi he was Ivan the Terrible he
wasn't having a terrible not - yeah but
you can't convict all like the grunts
the SS guys you can go after ya the
grunt guys you can't imprison all of
them right cuz they were just washed and
no just soldiers like anyone else there
was another country they thought they
were on the winning team when it but
like that worked at the concentration
camps you gotta go after but also then
after the Nuremberg trials this is what
happened was a lot of people high up
nineties went to prison for three is
five years right and but then after it
all played out in history then when we
started catching people in the 90s we
were like death penalty yeah yeah
and so they like me so there is that
dilemma that goes on no I want to say
very quickly I don't agree with the
punishment to be consistent I just watch
this for not fit and also I like with
the making a murder in the Michael
Jackson thing i watch that document i
watch the documentary before it came out
and I was watching other people's
documentaries like this person didn't
can didn't like the what's the word
speak at the trial for the other kid
right right and I'm like oh this
person's lying his press is like I got
well these are a couple of lives I think
Michael Jackson was dodgy but these
people would just ask for money and then
I watch the documentary I'm like well
but that's not that's not that you are
persuaded by something you think is
persuasive yeah you believe people
that's actually a good thing you'd
strike me as someone who's incredibly
fair and that's what I want to ask you
if you've seen the staircase say oh
that's the one with the woman with the
owl yeah yeah I've seen that yeah the
one with the wait I believe that the owl
did it yeah I don't I don't know if he
did it
I don't I don't think he fucking did it
but I think he's a lot of things I think
he's a narcissist I think he's a
psychopath I think he's like I just
don't think I'm really just obsessed
with human nature and I'm obsessed with
I don't think if you killed someone you
would invite a camera crew to be in your
home for three months I think he's done
a lot of bad things but I don't think he
can what about Scott and I see the woman
in Scott Peters stop please I don't know
that much about it but my gut is just by
hearing what you just said is that he
did it I believe he did it but I don't
believe he should be in prison why I
don't know because there's nothing about
the evidence the evidence isn't enough
really there's reasonable doubt I think
he did it
yeah but there haven't got enough on him
what happened with him was they found he
was a philanderer and a terrible husband
and I he was a shitty human bein yeah
and so then you went shitty human bein
he should go down he is a shitty human
bein isn't enough evidence that he do
but that's what we do I think as humans
we get this sort of collective evidence
we go he did this they of course he
killed no there's a lot of Liars in
Psychopaths and selfish narcissist who
actually aren't killers and a lot of
times the people are the most dangerous
are the ones that come off the most
normal why do
think women like guys on death row
because that's a real thing because that
is a human nature 101 thing we are
attracted on a very primal level I know
I'm gonna get a lot of shit to this for
men that are dangerous and on a
primordial reptilian brain level can
protect our babies and you think like I
can change him or you'd like in his time
well there's that that depends on your
childhood if you were raised in an
alcoholic home or around you know I mean
that's like a case-by-case thing but we
have a primal attraction the same way a
guy looks at a girl that walks by with
big boobs or big hips or big lips if
she's fertile when you look at a guy
with tattoos or engaging in risky
behavior is that person can protect my
baby I think it's because women like to
know where you are no they can't cheat
on us at least not with other women a
man that in prison is in prison at least
we know what they're doing at all times
Ted Bundy impregnated a woman while he
was in Detroit but I think we also have
to remember like I get in these fights
all the time we're live all you know
women are in love with Ted Bundy like
it's not all of us you know there's
these enough of all of us and what did
Casey Anthony she's not a bad-looking
girl did she a lot of people say I look
like her but during that trial I got a
lot of Casey Anthony side by side she
was not unattractive and what did she do
it's very clearly killed her child very
clearly but there's a lot of mental
illness in this world but that's mental
illness that's not being a woman those
two things are not synonymous what
mental illness and being a woman yeah
they're not not so nominees is anonymous
a lot of people I think that when a
woman is mentally ill and does something
horrific guys want to go see told you
like no that's a mentally ill person
that's not man woman that's just a very
sick all right yeah I worked with like
who did the most heinous murder in LA
history Oh
these names are Blake libel and he was
he was an intern on legit what yeah he's
an internal legit this is one of Jim's
chest yeah and he was like he's to sit
around he's Canadian Blake and used to
sit around the writers room going oh
yeah you guys are doing real good
that's while killers me anyways Darby
writer now he was the son of a
billionaire who was a property guy he
was like the Canadian Trump and
he has two brothers and one brother he's
like sort of cool and hangs out with
DiCaprio and drives a Ferrari and plays
in that card game in the yeah there's a
famous like card game amongst like
celebrities they made a movie about it
which 100 allan loeb won something I
mean Dame Amy
Oh Molly's game oh yeah the woman said
the aaron sorkin one yeah so anyway so
so Blake is this dopey guy who didn't
say that he had parents money he said
that he was he goes I'm a you mean you
hired him off of merit alone no Chris
case ago right with met him at Soho
House and he used to farm around he
became Chris's sort of lucky boy we'd
bring his coffees and stuff like that
and he wanted to be a writer and he was
a comic book writer and I was and then
he used to drive up in like a Porsche
911 we were like how do you get this we
didn't know he had this big inheritance
we're not paying you and he's like he's
like oh I just deal with the stocks and
then and then we started taking stock
tips from him the guy was a moron all of
his stock tips related to oh you gotta
buy him in EA Sports because there's a
new game coming out as all little
whatever video game that he was buy a
drink red Bull Red Bulls producing a new
beverage and you go to invest yeah I
would take these stock tips from this
killer anyway so he had this he had a he
had a wife when he had a kid with her
the kid was about five and then he she
was pregnant with a second kid and then
he got another woman I think a Ukrainian
woman pregnant getting people pregnant
is so like what are you doing we just
pull why is this so hard yeah but you
don't - and what is that I got one no no
but I'm just saying like pull it
together yeah yeah and sorry sorry sorry
don't you find it refreshing I feel like
guys don't climax inside women anymore
they want to do it on your boob no I
haven't comments on a woman and I have a
six seven years for preference or two is
used to it yeah I know so I like it
yeah pulling out now I always I'd like
to see it there's also that that walk
that the woman does when she has come in
that's really where I always find that
like apologetic you know you have no
reverse cuz I'm sorry about that oh
there's a lot in here okay all right
we'll fix that
that is awful that walk to the bathroom
where you're like squeezing like doing a
key goal to try to hold it in or just
the noise of a water come falling out
it's just the least I like when you have
to hear it when it hits the toilet where
they stand up and it hits the floor to
say that not all vaginas are designed
don't have a fistula where come I don't
think this coming falling out from deep
I think it was around the mouth of the
entrance the entry I mean I think lips
is something men would say I would never
say pussy lips and what has lips
I know but mouth just makes it sound
suit because then I think of teeth
oh my producers telling me labia labia
labia is one part that well I've never
quite no not I know the clitoris I know
the hole but yeah I know the hole I
don't do the hole and I know how to do
the clitoris like well versed in those
two things I do think most guys don't
know the difference between a labia and
the clitoris
I do think that the vagina is placed in
a bad part of the body it's it is kind
of far back too close to the asshole
yeah the amount of times I'm spooning a
woman don't don't put your dick there
now I'm gonna get an infection I'm like
are we trying to put it near your ass
all I was trying to have it knee yeah
the vaginal area and then it's like
question the the vagina should be up in
the shoulder
somewhere somewhere far away from the
asshole
I think that to horrific openings that
have horrific things come out of them
should definitely be in the same place
no no and it's on you you know these
days crap coming out of it as well
you know this isn't a fun hole it's not
it's socially acceptable to have on your
face every hole has something bad coming
out of it every hole you is getting
earwax coming out your asshole but shit
your dick has piss coming out of it your
mouth you vomit out of yes it's not
there's no hole that is gone even your
eye your eye has gunk in the fucking
morning every hole is producing fucking
shit we are constantly using disgusting
forms of Sh magma agree but if a vagina
is on a shoulder it's just I don't want
really hey your shoulders bleeding
really
living well is just keeping all your
holes in check it's really it's wack
keep the various substances from using
all over the place it's really we are
just we're animals we were disgusting
boozing organisms of trash we get into
these your sweatpants around for the day
yes they are if you're watching this on
YouTube but I'm wearing actual
sweatpants right but you are sick of
microwave leftovers and frozen pizza
enter door - restaurant quality food
with a living room dress code this is
our dream the only thing I want door -
connects you to your favorite
restaurants in your city ordering is
easy open the door - app choose what you
want to eat and your food will be
delivered to you wherever you are this
is just called magic yeah literally is
called magical heaven not only is your
favorite pizza joint already on door -
but there are over 340,000 restaurants
in 3300 cities so you might not find a
new favorite - that's my favorite thing
finding a new thing you didn't existed a
block away with door-to-door delivery in
all 50 states of Canada order from your
local go to or choose from your favorite
national treasures like Chipotle one
day's chick-fil-a and The Cheesecake
Factory
that called wet days I have a big lake
drama with say how dare you don't worry
about dinner I don't let dinner come to
you right now our listeners can get five
dollars off their first order of 15
dollars or more when you download the
door - app and enter promo code Whitney
Whitney how dare you that's five dollars
off your first order when you download
the door - app from the app store I keep
saying the wrong numbers from the app
store and enter promo code Whitney don't
forget promo code Whitney Whitney
Whitney for five dollars off Whitney
five dollars off your first order door -
five dollars off Whitney Whitney get it
right you got it I trust you I believe
in you let's do it
but I do think a guy's not enough guys
note you cannot go from the tushie to
the vagina yeah and point go back and
ruin that I'd really have because I
think I think it's okay young men think
that's a night guy thing nope that's a
UTI what happen you can't and I think a
lot of women the moment don't want to be
the buzzkill their leg up no you picked
your hole that's the hole now yeah once
you go there you don't get to you can go
from the ass from the vagina to the
asshole but you can't go back that's
correct
[Laughter]
metaphor in life there I don't know what
it is there's some career thing there
yeah that's actually true and you have
to earn it
[Laughter]
the irony it's not the same because it
is not cleaner and also there's no kids
accepted up there I like when so I like
when someone sits in like a plane and
there's a crying baby and they go what
do you want them to do I know they have
to travel with this you can't leave it
at home you know what I learned a friend
of mine comedian who has a kid and a
baby used to tour all the time and was
bummed when there were babies now that
he has one he's like Oh what I didn't
realize is the people with the baby
don't care that you're pissed yeah
they're just worried about your baby so
you being pissed doesn't hurt them at
all
you're just seething in your own fucking
anger doesn't but isn't it the thing
that I actually think about when babies
aren't playing says I worry about their
little ears popping yeah there is pop
that's why they cry yeah that psycho fan
landing if it's way in between and
they're bored the fact that you're
annoyed by a baby's being in pain on a
plane is so selfish oh I had a I had a
flight back the other day and there was
a 80 or 81 year old woman sitting next
to me and we got chatting and she used
to be
English teacher she lives in Beverly
Hills my husband's a doctor and I just
went to a bar mitzvah in Seattle right
we were flying down and the planes was
really light and she goes my driver I
couldn't stay anymore she's a lady you
had a regular driver yeah yeah and and
then she goes I guess I'll go home with
uber and now they've done that thing at
LAX and she goes I've never used do
before so I downloaded the app for I put
it in there and then I'm like yeah I'll
wait with ya took like an hour
she goes you're such a nice man she goes
Jim Jefferies she goes I'm gonna have to
look you up I get let's just leave the
relationship where it is you like me you
know I like you we nailed that shit no
need to look each other's history up no
no problem no mission is the key to a
good relationship I was efficient like
this let me call your mother I have to
tell her what a nice young man you know
I'm back when people did that and you
were like she's dead he's dead but even
if she wasn't it would be a weird call
yeah - Australia yeah time zones and
everything I have listened to you on a
couple things lately and you talked
about your mom passing and I it's so
funny because before I lost a parent I
truly when people talked about their
parents it passed I was like ah who
cares it happens we know what's gonna
happen it happens everyone that's the
one thing in life we know that's gonna
happen and people talk about I'm like
what's the big deal baby because I
didn't have great relationships and my
parents and and I lost my father year
and a half ago and it really does I felt
change you on a very cellular level it
makes you realise your own mortality
that's right it also for me I found I
lost a little bit of my moral compass
not that I don't have morals anymore but
I remember thinking I was doing stupid
things
yeah gotta don't want my mom to see this
interesting yeah I mean don't want to
listening to these now I'm just the cunt
said be in the shoulder that's way too
have you on to your mom like you've
written some books people offered me
book deals I'm like I don't know if I
can write this before my mom dies I do I
remember I have wrote a whole chapter
about my relationship with my dad and
right before it came out I had
pull it is that was so afraid of him
reading it yeah yeah and even if it's
honest you dislike because because
you've come to peace with it yeah it
doesn't need to be brought up again now
me and my mother a lot of people say
when you pass away they go don't leave
anything left unsaid all right mmm-hmm
I'll tell you me and my mom too much
said no more subtext towards the end we
went over we went over that relationship
before she died we went over everything
what about that time you hit me then and
no reparation look I had I'm really big
on forgiveness and it's like something
I'm gonna toss that program and we say
we forgive not because they deserve
forgiveness but because we deserve peace
yeah this whole thing we were like beat
up on our parents all the time they grew
up in a generation they didn't have
tools they did the best they fucking
could well I I my father's coming to
stay with me for a couple of months and
so there will be the most amount of time
I've spent with him in well over 20
years
yeah and he's pretty right-wing he's
very right-wing I can't leave my
father's a trumpet and and so he goes
why they come for one month or two
months and he said this to my brother
and he goes we'll see if we get along
right and I love my dad I believe we get
along and my brother went why don't you
just don't mention Trump my dad went I
don't know if I can do that
because I don't bring up politics I just
know we're politically in the wrong and
it's not just Trump it's everything yeah
yeah I mean and my dad's like right-wing
American but he enjoys all the left-wing
Australian things like health care yeah
and you know like what are the things
like he would agree with abortion he
wouldn't think that he doesn't agree
with guns yeah yeah I mean yeah and so
he'd be a lefty over here yeah you know
but he likes Trump Trump says it out is
I get to me like in my day when two
people are in the same room and they
disagreed on things that was called an
interesting conversation yeah like for
me like we're in this echo chamber we
only hang out with people we agree with
that's part of the reason I love hanging
out with comedians so much because it we
least will play devil's advocate my
girlfriend's British from Indian descent
and my father my father
no just talks about too many Brown
immigrants
I know which brand immigrants he's
talking about but she's a brown
immigrant there's she offended a little
bit but she now knows that it was like
you know I my grandfather when I lived
in Virginia for why I remember he would
drop me off at school and he would
always ask me about how the colored kids
were doing he say like how are the
colored kids doing I'm like oh god you
can't say how are they doing quite fine
and you would ask all about their
studies and how the colored kids doing
and they'd come out any point and it
made me so embarrassed and I was so sick
to my stomach I was a cop my grandfather
such a racist he's such a racist and
then I found out the reason he was
asking me is cuz he was actually paying
for their tuition I wanted to know like
how they were doing paying for the
tuition you can say whatever word you
want it was this thing where I was like
you know what I remember in an early age
just going like words matter obviously
but I kind of was like I was calling him
racist in my and I thought he was racist
but he was just fucking all day he
worked in a Ford plant in Cleveland he
did he was in Virginia and like he just
didn't know he's not like he wasn't on
how did he work in coal mines here in
the mine how was he pretty yeah he ended
up having a peanut store in Virginia and
then making money and yeah peanut a
candy store in Roanoke Virginia and then
he started before he won had the
allergies you can make a killing on
peanuts before the 90s and now you just
kill people with pain that's right now
you're a murderer by the way you never
told us how your intern killed someone
the fact that anal sex is now more
interesting than mass murder I said
black libel and you can look this up
right so he let feel so bad for Blake
Lively than anyone who tries to Google
her and misspells it this guy so I blank
like he impregnated this other woman and
then he just saw so he had his wife
pregnant he had this girl pregnant and
he decided whether he was kicked out
from one place or whatever he went off
with the the the girlfriend right and so
he went with her he's still visiting his
kids and whatever getting hundred
thousand dollars a month from his dad
and you know
and what happened to bike was then he
there's some other things there was some
writer's assistant that he was dodgy
with and there was a few other things
anyway the woman gives birth to the kid
tells Blake to fuck off
two weeks after the child is born
Blake tries to contact a lot of stuff
her mother's flying out from the Ukraine
or wherever it is to come and see the
baby you know and the bike invites her
over to talk about their relationship
and she's never seen again well she just
time out when a relationship is over
there's nothing to talk about
there's no let's talk about how it's I
believe in once it's done it's done
there's no let's talk about why it's
over that's your that's a trap so she
comes over he he scalped her and drained
all of the blood out of her there was
less than a teaspoon of blood now to do
that the body has to stay alive to keep
pumping the blood she was alive for
maybe a week why he just cut off
different parts of limbs and all that
type of stuff and then they found a
comic book that he'd written earlier it
was all about scalping women I get I
start laughing when things are tragic
because I just can't handle it if I
start laughing judge me so he he he
fuckin yeah he drained alibi they say it
was the worst murder in LA history like
most graphic horrendous and like there
was all of her facial parts were put
through the garbage disposal and magnet
no she'd given birth two weeks earlier
and the mother he just locked himself in
the apartment and did the police said oh
she has to be missing for a few days the
mother was just crying at the front of
the door banging on the door and she was
taking care of the baby and then Blake
comes in he's like like please come and
he ordered post mates throughout the
whole thing
all right post baby was coming for days
why he was just cutting her up and and
it torn Achatz and stuff to keep her but
like alive goal I'm trying to ask what a
psychotic person's goal was but what was
he trying to give a psychotic break
mustard with blood all over him and on
top of stuff and they're like wow you're
killed and he was like I believe he said
yeah you should find the murderer
so is this like what it what did they
did a psychiatrist
some kind of evaluation we look this out
I don't know about the psychotic
evaluation but I know they did like a
Dateline or a 20/20 on the guy and I was
never asked I would have given a good
interview on this I never like like
everyone else in the room is alright I
never fucking like this guy was a tool I
remember feeling a little bit like I'm a
good judge of character because everyone
else was like I leave like a lot I got
Blake's creepy and I'd fucking lock like
I always talked about this we never
trust our guy there's a book right over
there called the gift of fear that's all
about that's his mug shot that's him
with the girlfriend saw her house where
he actually had the two kids and that's
the woman in the Hat there is the one
that's what he killed on the one the Hat
is the one that he killed yeah yeah that
one with the Datsun there is that one
the woman in the pink is his wife
dude that guy looks like a cartoon
serial killer he's got a lot of white
before he strong his eyes are completely
asymmetrical that's him when he gained
weight yeah it was ordering a lot of
post mates Jesus well that was eating
prison food he got fat but yeah he had
you know he still has like poor thing
the little kids are gonna start to ask
questions stuff but I like now like
Chris brought him into the office and
now whenever I work with Chris case
again I'm like man I picked the PA no
not in charge you brought Blake into it
okay so it was a torture and a murder
basically he barricaded her in his West
Hollywood apartment and she was 30 years
old Jesus Christ mutilated dried blood
infant daughter okay we know I am really
curious what was what she pleaded not
guilty he barricaded the apartment in
and everything and he's just sitting
there with bruises and scratches all
over him
what's exhaust you ination all right it
couldn't it couldn't be good and head
trauma it is oh it's basically he
trained her to death he drained her
blood that He shed listen to teaspoon of
blood left in her body he she bled to
death he might look like yeah like yeah
how you'd make beef jerky oh this is
what you do when you slaughter animals
yeah yeah yeah you drain the blood out
before you yeah if any
but he has that kind of complicated of a
murder this is something he's research
there's something he couldn't have done
it by accident that copies for what I
don't think he'd killed other people but
like he researched what he wanted to do
surely and then do they look up his like
cookies or some shit I was like how are
we gonna crack this cold it could
syndrome that was a picture of a baby
that was scalped on the cover so he was
like obsessed with scalping yeah that
was these thing I'm really curious
though but do they look at the past
Google searches I'm sure they do I'm
sure they must I would like to see that
yeah II know what he ordered on post man
it's just like I love getting into the
mind just a little sure yeah I can
change him
I also there was a in DC there was a
murder where this guy I actually talked
about it I'm in my favorite murder
podcast where he showed up he killed
four people tortured their kid just
horrific and they busted him cuz he had
ordered a Domino's Pizza and his DNA was
on the crust which they found in the
trash can that's right they're empty
cops but imagine being that I actually
wonder because whenever I order from one
of these delivery services I have dogs I
never I always do crack the door and I'm
like thank you like I imagine all these
delivery people are like half the people
I deliver do our murdering some do you
ever get noticed by the delivery person
yes yeah when they do that they go hey
Jim big fan man I'm like oh great and
then you're like yeah I got a tip good
okay I always tip pretty good but you
can't be like that just get 15% you
gotta go above and beyond that guy's
brain goes I go
great now you know where I live oh I
always bring my dogs to the gate with me
when I get it so people see my three
giant pit bulls The probe's are
sometimes I'm just in my underwear
mm-hmm I always feel like that's
embarrassing you just walk down in boxer
shorts and you're like yes this is what
I ordered it I love it what a guy's in
his underwear it's embarrassing and when
a girl is in her underwear it's like an
invitation no one sees me my underwear
guys oh I might go in there but actually
that looks like a lot of fun boxers are
way I wear those Calvin
boxer briefs they're a game change when
they came in because boxes are too
billowy and they look bad in trousers
yeah and then the other ones cut into
the bit between the scrotum and the leg
yeah and you can get like a bit sweaty
down there and then like the briefs the
big level I have a question before this
girlfriend were you single for a while
no I had another girlfriend so you kind
of alright yeah very long there yeah but
when you were single I like to ask guys
advice about dating stuff because I find
sometimes girls give bad advice and if
that is a generalization but I think for
the most part girls sometimes you know
especially if they know you well they
don't wanna hurt your feelings they you
know they're the girls will be like now
his phone is probably not working
like that's not a thing still or like he
probably just likes you too much oh you
know I look I I don't know I I went from
being with Hanks mother and it mean
Hanks mother I like people
people don't like it that we're so close
yeah it does it makes them very upset
like why aren't you still together
because this works a lot better yeah and
we see each other almost every day just
down the road I remember when I her in a
movie with God I was she was hanging
from a like a thing an angel waiting the
entire day that's that's kites normal I
did a little weird movie with he goes
boom that's right
and I was in a I've never watched it I
was in a candy you know those candy
necklaces a candy necklace bra and this
was before I got new boobs so I'm really
bummed
and then like weird little underwear and
then your your ex was hanging in her
underwear with angel wings she was meant
to be like a famous porn star or
something
that's right and she was flying or
something and it was a very low-budget
movie and what she was doing was
incredibly dangerous there were no stunt
people there were no I mean she's just
hanging and then we like broke for lunch
and people like I will see you in for
like she was hanging there for most of
the day like it was like at the
directors house it was like a super low
budget movie and a lot of people got
hurt yeah yeah I'm some really surprised
she she's still alive yes she made it
was she still around but I have a
question for you like when when you are
dead
a red flower major red flag in women
major red flag in women I think too much
too fast is always a red flag yeah that
depends if you really like the person
too much is okay I can be oxytocin and
dopamine and yeah what's a big red flag
I think I think if they if they talk
about other guys a lot yeah he's a red
flag like exes yeah I went yeah I like
the other way too when guys say that
their exes psycho I think that's a big
red flag you know I also a guy recently
told me that a red flag was their
Instagram only being photos of them is a
red flag oh I I don't I yeah if you if
you take a lot of selfies and isn't a
good thing it's that's like a mental
health thing now 100% because if you
take a picture of yourself and then the
next thing in your brain those people
must see this who I mean I can't deprive
and also for everyone so I think that's
a generational thing I mean they all do
yeah yeah but it's also for everyone
selfie you've taken 40 yeah you post
them one yeah you know I haven't taken a
picture of I'm trying to think like
people sending dick pics and stuff like
that I think I sent some dick pics very
early on in the camera phone history
like around 2000 am I am I allowed to
say everyone has those please let me
know pretty impressive shot for the
lighting was great but that was I I
never spent longer on a photo shoot I'm
really gonna get granular and then you
put things like from a distance for the
proportions and stuff like that you get
one of those small coke bowls they give
you on planes like here I go wow that's
a little mini Purell bottles exactly so
what is the logic of sending a dick pic
I'm not against dick pics by the way I
haven't done it in years
yeah well over a decade I haven't said a
dick pic this is Daniel I got a foot
phone yeah yeah and those grainy
pictures might look diseased but that's
just the resolution I do my dick
constantly looks like it's it's giving
our witness to a crime
anyway so i yeah i think at the dawn of
camera phones there was sort of like oh
we're doing this now yeah you know
because our that was the first time i
had naked pictures sent to me and i'm
laying and then they asked for it in
return I think I think the value in a
dick pic was this women who sent you
photos it was like they're a little bit
of ransom where they were like alright
well III gonna need a picture of your
dick so I'll send you you're a piece of
shit and you show everybody I've got a
picture your dick it's a good standoff
have now heard this logic that's a fish
now I don't think any woman gets a
picture of a dick and goes haha I'm in
for the night it's a negotiation tactic
it send me it send me your tits and I'll
send you my day yeah I think you'll send
me more so you'll trust me yes we're in
this together we're in this cage yeah
it's a give back and forth and I find it
weird like when celebrities now get
caught doing it you like unless it's
from ten years ago it's like what did
you think that's what I think was gonna
happen that's gonna happen like I think
like you know everybody sent everyone
sext each other yeah if sex I always
find that I I get upset when people get
in trouble for that when they get sent
like he sent me a dirty text she sent me
a dirty thing we're all in the
conversation it's just not like you
going I can't wait to see you buddy blah
blah blah yeah and they're like I'm
sleeping and then you could conversation
I mean I don't think that's right the
people do it's like there's I mean
there's always gonna be you know I'm
always I feel like I can I'm usually get
in trouble for saying this because I
like to be kind of down the road about
it's just like digs like they're not
that big of a deal to me if I don't want
to see it I'll just delete it I don't
use snapchat now but when I did women
would just send me naked pictures but
not that often by here that women would
just get loads of dicks sent to him yes
I do I get lots and I actually did that
h3h3 podcast the other day and I
actually I actually think I just think
they're funny I mean I think the only
thing probably worse for guys than
saying I don't want your dick pics is
saying like I look at them and I laugh
and I show them to my friends like I
have a text shame with Rogen and
Julianne Swartz and I just send them to
them and we make fun of you because I'm
pretty obsessed with the background of
the photo the dick is like whatever but
I like to see like people's bathrooms
and bad guys I when you see all these
different dick pics
is there ever one where you go that's a
majestic pain I'll show you some I like
my dick I'm not a big fan of it if I
meant it in a bar and have a drink with
it like this is this is an example I got
this dick pic oh and let's say that's a
young man with a very long slender plate
this is all I care about
zoom in look at those headphones hanging
from the towel rack why do you think
that's weird
who puts their headphones on their towel
rack it's just it's bizarre to me and
that's all I care about
I like to see the mundane things that
people do in their lives and what it
seems to be like drippings on the wall
or something there what's this guy this
is a big hot angle yeah that's a good
angle but lower the tattoo in the chest
that's it yeah but I'd love to like just
see people's weird-ass choices I'm sorry
did I just do you converse with him or
ladies no no no they send them I mean
Benton mostly checks my DM so he has to
look at all of them and I know he's
gonna sue me at some point because this
cannot be this is definitely a hostile
work environment but I think I think
there's a couple things you're really
making me think because now that we have
high-res photos I don't think you guys
understand that sometimes you have zits
on your dick I don't think it's the same
as bumps from hair follicles or
something or maybe it's an ingrown hair
the ingrown hairs are more common you
have to pluck or exfoliate or something
cuz a lot of guys are sending dick pics
where they have like weird little herpe
ingrown hairs
yeah ingrown hairs and a good actual
dick acne is a lot rarer dick acne yeah
it's probably a clogged pores just a
clogged pore I had one that was assist
ones that clog pull it became a cyst
yeah I had to have it like cut out about
couple of stitches that was a bad time
because there's also a lot of guys
trying to shave because I think they're
seeing it in porn but yeah so I just
trimmed down his chimney just with
scissors clippers
do you have to like hunched over no III
do it nicely I sit on the toilet so all
the hair falls down I sleep with me legs
piled on the toilet like I like that
it's not the most beautiful shop you
would have of a person but I can you
know and I do it if you see if I've
trimmed my beard down because I don't
shave I just use the Clippers on my
beard you can count on it that my
testicles are also trimmed down but if
I'm overgrown in the face that means
everything's overgrown
I'll do everything on the one die so
whatever's going on in your face is
what's going on in your moment this is
the lines I've got going down on my dick
right now it would be weird to have more
hair on your face than on your scrotum
yeah I think so I don't have a
particularly hairy body as such I don't
have like you know hairy back or
anything I don't do any of that where
did you do land on women in their body
hair women always want to know do men
give a shit I don't mind a little bit of
bush but I want it sort of shortish I
don't like long especially to go down
and if it's a long yeah you don't want
it to be about steel wool I've been here
this is one of these things that I'm
like I like to be a person that just
goes ah in women should have the hair on
their body that they want but I'm a
little bit turned off by armpit hair but
that's just I don't know something in my
head that I don't like it right but leg
hair as long as it's not you know you
messy I don't care if it's a bit stubble
you're something or you between waxes
I'd rather have hair than stubble on a
guy I'd rather you had castable rubs and
you get rug burn and you're bleeding
like I'd rather you just grow it out and
have it be long than me get you know man
burn yeah I'd like like I know women who
wax their arms
that's yours a fuck about hairy arms I
don't know I think that a lot of this is
self-cam cannibalizing that's what I
like to ask guys about it cuz a lot of
times women we put these impossible
standards on ourselves and like no one's
forcing you to do any of this shit do
women still bleach their lips I thought
you were to say asshole yeah do they
still do that's on the run yeah I don't
think it works I tried it a couple times
I don't think it works and there's
bleaching Russell yeah I went to Vegas I
was performing in Vegas and I got this
like DM that was like will do a free
asshole bleaching for you the guys down
he's got a earphones hanging from the
rack don't lose a carrot tops bathroom
and so I was like okay and I just went
and I think was like the beginning of
social media when I was like oh you can
get free shit out of this and I went and
it was like this topical thing that had
to sit on for like 30 minutes and then I
like doing your teeth yeah it's like a
white strip for your butthole then I had
to reapply this gel every day for like
three months and I was like I don't like
touching my own butthole I'll tell you
about this right no no man ever goes I
liked her but her asshole was too dark
in color no one's ever know and that's
why I also think about the the lip
injections I feel like women are more
into lip injections than men are I also
think the fake tanning mmm-hmm
no no man's ever had sex with a woman
then afterwards gone she was alright
great body good tits nice ass but if the
skin is just slightly darker slightly
because I like being pale I've gotten
used to so much in Australia for being
as pale as I am when I'm as pale as they
come and then and then in Britain I felt
like a normal person and but I hate when
I go on TV and there's a new makeup
person and they want to give me a bit of
colour
no no I'm okay with it yeah just get rid
of the dark circles we'll move on I
think obviously with the tanning I think
guys like I really like this girl but
she left Tanner all over a fucking right
on the bed we're out of Turin yeah it's
got that funky coppery smell well it's
actually so interesting just like
historically because it used to be being
pale meant you were part of the
aristocracy it means you weren't working
out in the fields you know that everyone
desired to be pale and now having money
and being part of the elite means that
you're tan because it means you go on
vacation and all that stuff yeah
interesting how it's changed throughout
history the value on that Trump you can
tell anyways you guys do tanning beds
cuz he wears those little glasses and
that's when you get the white under the
warrant circle yeah and that's not a
good look either I used to do that I
used to tan with an instrument I squared
the tanning beds when I was a teenager
and I remember I would get so tan but my
face just because you wash your face and
because you exfoliate your face you can
never truly match so I look like this
weird fucking geisha it was never a good
look but I do think there is just this
impossible standard beauty we're all
just trying to chase and it's just like
a weird addiction like if used if we all
stop doing half of the shit that we're
doing I don't think your men would stop
fucking us I'm not I'm not like I've had
me taste done I think you look great
they look at what did you have because
they look totally real - yeah yeah I had
a natural I didn't go to Y days yeah
they just like that crazy white III and
I take tablets for my hair and those
tablets are like the worst that's the
main fear for men yeah I wasn't
vision I probably wouldn't worry as much
uh-huh I would just fuck it and just
clip her it off right I just I hold on
to every strand you know what's
interesting is that in studies women we
should pull this up and we should I
should do a thing on the next one so I'm
actually getting the science rate of how
men are give off more of an alpha vibe
when they're bald right and women are
more testing more testosterone
yeah good to have it you know if you
want to be like jason stathom looks
that's right or there's just something
hot about a guy that like doesn't give a
fuck yeah I don't know if it I look I'd
like to keep as much air as as possible
but it's I I hate I hate when men get
told off for wearing wigs
I think that's appalling in our society
because women were wigs or extensions
they having they're having a bit of fun
they're having a bit of fun no no
problem here fake ponytails and all this
type of bullshit mmm fat man was a weak
loser
but I'm so curious about when that shame
started cuz our founding fathers just
wore wigs all the time dude you should
wear long curly wig yeah it's like it's
like when Phil Spector went to trial the
whole story was about him and his wigs
he killed a woman he killed her and that
also happened but everyone's like did
you say the wig II was wearing he's
crazy like someone where are we on the
toupee technology though I think no I
think it's very good I think wigs people
tase them but only the ones you know
that's right well that's the other thing
that they say cuz I remember I went to
this dermatologist and every time I go
to a dermatologist in LA they try to
tell me to like put shit in my face
which people already think I've done so
I might as well fucking do it at some
point but everybody I said to him I was
like you know I don't look crazy cuz I
get dark circles nothing what do I do
and I was a kind of a little crazy and
everyone that gets plastic surgery looks
crazy he's like no no no the good one
you don't notice and most people have it
they just got the right one so probably
the same with the toupee I had I had
lipo on my chin those those things so I
had it here and then now what happens is
it looks better
I used to have no chin there but now if
I gain weight these bits grow down the
side
what does that mean cuz it opened this
ski this fit was pulled back under here
but this bit here wasn't anything with
touch so it looks alright as long as I
keep my white down but if I get white it
looks really weird like Mitch McConnell
people are doing now someone's tell me
about is it's called threading they put
a string to make your your chin line I'm
not I'll probably get sued if I say
which celebrities have it but to make
your chin line sharper they put a string
behind your ear right it's called the
sugar sugar threading and then they put
it underneath and it just pulls
everything back surgery if you feel it
makes you feel better about yourself and
you look better and you you want to do
it for personal reasons or for work or
whatever if I can have at it I don't
believe in aging gracefully fucking do
it kicking and screaming you're gonna
get fucked if you do in front of you
known so it's like you know if you if
you wear a toupee they're gonna be like
oh you weren't a toupee and if you don't
amigo your ball this is like fuck you
that was another thing about Marvin
Jackson he looked like a fucking freak
but didn't look 50 everybody you know
used to make fun of the fact that I had
eye bags and then I did all this allergy
stuff to stop it and then look well you
got a facelift and you got face implants
it's like what you're gonna and then now
people go like you know they used to say
you lie about your age you're older than
you are and I wasn't lying about my age
and now that I'd like take care of
myself and know how to put makeup on
they're like you got plastic surgery
like I can't fucking win with you guys
if you if you wanted to lie about your
age that's your prerogative as well
that's fuckin business
no but I've always looked older than I
am and now that I actually look my age
people think I'm lying I'm just like I
can't win I always like getting a year
older because then I think oh my hair
looks more plausible now now that I like
kind of look my age people think I'm
lying I like grew into my face no idea
what the hanging out with the comedian
and we were hanging out with some people
that he went to school with over there
and we all look the youngest and we're
all the same age I'm like I think this
job keeps you young
that's interesting I think it does I
think just the whole idea of not because
you dress younger or something like that
just not working 9 to 5 in a grind and
doing something you love keeps you
looking relatively like young because
there's a lot of comedians that I know
my generation they're all drug abusers
and smokers and drinkers yeah we're
pretty good yeah I do notice everyone I
know that did heroin looks really and I
always look ripped heroin bodies are the
best something happens with heroin where
you just lock into this shape
are you embalmed like this is an I want
to try fucking hair Iggy Pop or
something that type of heroin and I
don't know if it's the kind of
personality that does heroin or when you
get sober you have to work so hard to
get another addiction you know like
exercise becomes your addiction or food
starving yourself becomes you always I
always thought there was a sweet spot
with aids as well there was just a one
before really kicked in where you lost
the right amount of weight and you're
like alright because there was that bit
where like Freddie's taking care of
himself no there is gone too far now and
I'm because I'm always like chicken hang
about it I'm like did you get into
heroin because you were so good-looking
and nobody would call you on your shit
you know it's easier to be a heroin
addict if you're hot and sexy because
more people will put up with your shit I
think there was also I feel like drugs
now have a different stigma to what I
had in the 90s where we had heroin chic
models yeah that's right I don't think
it's as cool as it was now thanks and it
used to just be a very cool thing mhm
I remember a comedy club in Britain I
was told off for having cocaine on me
and and the club owner said how dare you
buy cocaine bring cocaine in my club
right and I was like so sorry guys if if
you want to have cocaine you buy it from
Andrew at the door he was unhappy that I
was bringing in or bringing other drug
dealers may come into his club because
one of his security Stoll solved the
drugs and that's where I was meant to
get it always a respect your fucking
with the mom-and-pop basically I would
get very scared of buying drugs on the
road oh it was a different time people
weren't lysine things with fentanyl
that's right that's right you know you
could do it it was a drug dealers were
more all back then Britain was a
different vibe as well back in the early
2000s Britain was a different thing with
drunks it just was more everyone was
doing it yeah and I know that sounds
silly everyone was doing but this
generation it's not like that anymore
now it's like that you hear stories from
the comedy store where that little glass
piano that's right with all the cuts on
it
everyone they go on prize Robin Williams
and pry used to do coke off this there's
lines cut could you imagine cutting it
up now no just pulling it out of the bag
and just chatting to someone
quasi Li pulling it out and just doing
it on that table every comic I know I
don't think I've ever seen a comedian do
cocaine I don't think I've ever seen a
comedian do cocaine now that I'm
thinking I know some that did but I
never saw it but now in Comedy Store
green rooms everyone's got like a
pressed juice or in their probiotics and
the vegan protein bar the comedy
communities become very healthy and too
many people died yeah when Geraldo died
I remember that's when everyone was like
we gotta get Americans and the
painkillers man the prescription stuff
that's filed it beats the fuck out of me
yeah so you don't do any of this I don't
know I've never taken prescription drugs
never taken I've never abused this
prescription or drunk it's I do remember
when I was in college I got my I finally
got health insurance and I got molars
removed you know and I come from addicts
like I have an addictive personality
that is just like and I got a percocet I
don't even know if they still prescribed
percocet hmm and I slept for two days
and I've always been insomniac and I
literally was like I could do this
forever yeah why would anyone not only
do I take the occasional antics on a
plane if I'm doing a long-haul flight
yeah but now I take like a lot of
edibles when I fly yeah like and then I
sit there and laugh my ass off at some
juvies by myself keep this ordering food
I do feel like the edibles the dosing
they gotta figure out the dose Oh exact
science are these blueberries or five
milligrams each and then one blueberry
will knock down your ass take four
sometimes it'll do nothing no idiot
you're really playing Russian roulette
with those those are the different size
totally you can say that one's a lot
bigger than that one you don't know and
they put it all in a big batch and then
they spit them out then some of it might
have a lot more weed at the bottom yeah
yeah I don't know but it's not an exact
I know Joey Diaz on a podcast because he
did a thousand milligram one that would
kill me I would go into a psychosis and
I also just don't know when it's
metabolized out of you and you know like
sometimes I feel like for a couple days
I'm a little bit groggy and I'm like
what's my home address like I just I
don't like that I just like a precision
which I've started doing is have you
ever had hard
bucho I've had kombucha what do you mean
by hard kombucha has a little bit of
alcohol in it and it's just like the
perfect amount to just like fall asleep
because I've always had insomnia oh I
see you say this in Sonya I've always
thought I had insomnia at my whole life
oh I can't sleep I can't see no and then
what happened was when I made legit and
my son was born at the same time so I
was working 12-hour days and I had a
baby yeah I was going to sleep fine Yeah
right
it just turned out that I was doing
nothing yeah and I was lying down all
day and they would get the bedtime it'll
be like just did that I can't sleep
there was no there was no caveman who
chased after a saber-toothed tiger and
then came back to his cave like oh god
I'm up all night he was passing out in a
fucking rock his wife was there from all
the gathering she was passed out no was
insomniac there is something well back
then they had something called night
Watchers and I talked to the
psychiatrist who's explaining to me that
my epigenetics might just be night
watcher DNA which is back then because
there were no lights there were people
who would basically have a the opposite
they'd be nocturnal essentially and they
would stay up all night such as shift
work that's it sleep all day and that's
been inherited from in the epigenetics
of I just might have you know thousands
of years ago the tribe I was in my grave
you and nappa I tried a nap but I have
really bad if I hear one knows I get
very adrenalized III have that as well I
I can I wake up swinging yep me too I'm
like punch me too
so that's what I'll do if I can fall
asleep so excite grew up in an alcohol
calm and that one noise could mean
something really crazy is about to
happen so if I'm falling asleep and I
hear like a leaf blower or a bang or
like a house sound or some time up I get
really adrenalized and I get angry right
and then there's then that that ship is
say okay I had a bad home invasion many
years ago with some people broke in and
I heard about this and I didn't want to
ask you about it cuz I figured you just
sick I think they're out of prison by
now but I just a couple of guys tied me
up and how do you come back from that I
didn't live in a house for a long time I
only lived in apartments because I came
through the window and I thought I
wouldn't live in a ground-floor and then
I just got over it I just stop worrying
about it
it wasn't something that's not like that
no you do empty are any
- no I went to a few therapists I don't
know if therapy works for me I still
give it a go all the time I go to a
therapist a couple of times a month and
is it because I think really smart
people therapy sometimes is tricky
because you can I think the problem with
comedians are we're already good at
talking I just talk to you for an hour
and a half we haven't really asked a
question well we're just good at talking
yeah so it's not like I need to get my
emotions out like it's like what what I
said with me and my mother I talk to
many people my emotions yeah it's too
much too much knowing about me yeah I
don't think you're going in I think
therapy in unless you're going in with a
very specific goal of something you want
to change about yourself and your
therapist is really down with neurology
and knows how to change your neural
pathways and you're willing to do the
work it's nice to talk to people about
mistakes that you've made and regrets
that you have yes that's what I use it
for and then things like that when I'm
feeling about like a bag of shit about
my life about you know stupid shit I've
done like release shame I like to really
shame and also you feel like you're you
were taking ownership of it then because
you're going to try to better yourself
yeah and also just not going to the
problem for the solution so that's what
we do all the time right it's like I'm
gonna fight with my boyfriend or
whatever it is I'm gonna go to my
boyfriend to try to solve it a person
who caused the problem is probably not
the first you can solve the problem
the idea is go to someone else figure
out the solution then bring the solution
to the relationship type thing I want to
ask you something because I did a little
thing on Instagram where I said people
asked Jim Jefferies you know questions
like that what should I ask that people
want to know and I want to know this
because I never want to be too inside
Hollywood in on this show but you are
doing a show at NBC now yeah right and
I'm just so curious and as someone who
has done a lot done television and has
been in nightmare development deals for
the last four years and has had my heart
broken and then has you know you have to
have the right team you have success
isn't values a little bitter and
sometimes what are perceived failures
are actually successes I think doing a
couple of seasons of a show why is that
that's killer why is that not good
enough for people getting something
through the pilot system and on the air
you're already all singers a lot of
shows should be 40 episodes yeah no one
no one looks at the British office and
goes for 12 episodes what a failure
yeah exactly you know but I think I mean
English television does it really well
they do
a lot of times they're comedies are six
episodes you know four seasons like I
mean a lot of shows shouldn't be a
hundred and fifty episodes that know I
always thought with legit like sorry I
just a fill in people who done all the
show as it was a show about me living
with a guy who was a friend of mine and
he's disabled brother which was
something I did in real life yeah my
best friend had a brother with muscular
dystrophy and the I wanted the show to
go for four seasons because that
character with muscular dystrophy had to
die no eventually because he was sick
when we met him and dying and we
couldn't go to ten seasons you know the
medicines got better and now he's like
so I never wanted to go from one four
seasons and I had a story arc that I
wanted it to end with all the way
through but we ended after two but it
was a good show I was happy with the
show but I think a lot of people when
they asked cuz I think a lot of people
listening to it have watched the shows
you know that we've done it like why did
that show end it was like you know oh I
always liked this one are you going to
do any more acting and I was like that's
always like that's a question every
interview are you gonna do any more
acting and I always go that's the same
as asking me and I am I gonna have sex
with any more models it's it's up to
them that's what I would like to I'm
open to the idea that's not my decision
but also I think that when people you
know I sometimes getting these weird
conversations at airports because people
come up to me and they like to give me
career advice and they're like why
weren't you wonder woman
yeah yeah and I'm like I forgot to call
them back that's why and also but no one
considers the fact that maybe we've also
passed on things because I think a lot
of people don't attend a lot of us
especially comedians like we lose money
actually yeah acting does not pay bills
I've had a few acting jobs that I've
passed I was going to be on one day at a
time
oh yeah one day time I was gonna be like
Schneider oh yeah but then I chose to do
the Jim Jeffrey show it was just like oh
it was the same time I think you
probably made the right yeah but then
there's like life would've been pretty
chill there man you just be like the
maintenance guy in an apartment you come
see and every now and again like oh yeah
who needs that pipes fixed or whatever
the fuck it is
you'd be like Larry from Three's Company
exact
I'm just gonna have a tool belt on the
whole time I could see that and then I
had a I had a movie that I couldn't do
that was while the show was filming as
well that I really want to do it was
like there was like a part with like
Jeremy Irons
and don't say Piven I was like yeah
Jeremy Irons and I was like that would
have been Diane Keaton ah and then and
then and that didn't happen I think
that's filming like film like last month
or something and then now there's a
little sick bit of my brain where I'm
like I hope that film doesn't do too
well
I just get really fascinated with
someone look why don't you do more
acting like do more acting roles that's
like saying like I really like your
personality but I'd love to see you as a
different one yeah I don't like you that
my want to go see you pretend you're
someone else you know I would like to be
a gun for hire on a job where I don't
have to produce it or anything me too
that's literally what I'm where I'd show
up and I'm like hosting a show mm-hmm
just doing a game show I reckon I could
do a game SHINee you'll be great at a
game show but also we say I would love
to be hired for someone else's thing but
then you have to surrender to the fact
that not everything that's written
you're gonna necessarily like well
what's the old saying that like success
has many parents and failure as an
orphan right so every time your TV show
does well all the executives and stuff
like yeah we all will did it in the show
file yeah sorry Jim you just didn't take
our notes or whatever and then it's your
fault that the show face well that's and
so I'd like to be in one of the ones
where I'm just one of the many parents
if it does well because when you're
writing producing acting you're the
goalie yeah you're the one that gets all
the blame yeah and there's a lawsuit
you know when they don't really know
there's 200 other people and nine guys
that went to law school told me that I
you know needed to change a joke no knew
nothing about comedy so I think it's
also like the last couple deals that
I've been in it was just sort of like Oh
creatively we're not seeing the same way
and there's no point in us doing this
I'm already getting a little bit of
backlash on why don't look at the
internet so I imagine you got many nasty
questions about you actually didn't
people people really liked you and I
think it's I heard you say somewhere
that you don't really look at social
media I don't look at any responses I
think that you would be surprised at how
much people like you first on Twitter I
press verified so I can see if like
people I know the
follow ya run it but that's you know
obviously not all my friends aver
literally the first one he's my favorite
this is not a slash that's not a
question literally right there just he's
my favorite what was the question you
had to ask about the show about the show
you're doing yes I was just kind of
curious like you know I'm really
obsessed with what makes people happy
and what makes people feel full and what
works for lack of a better word and it's
like you're such a revered comedian you
made so many incredible specials you had
an I loved your show or thanks and you
are gonna start a podcast at some point
like you're financially solvent yeah
why do you now want as someone who does
this why do you want to go through the
machine I think the thing behind the
multicam was I'm a big fan of I haven't
done that it yeah I mean so I've done
I've done
do you think is a multicam the other
thing was single camera then I did a
desk like like a Tonight Show type of
thing like a news even more thing and
then I'm like I haven't done a multicam
yeah when I first did it like they sort
of M EC sort of pitched it to me I got
brought in for a general meeting and I
had no idea why I've never gone from
meeting with NBC I didn't think that the
network would want me or anything like
that I walked out of the meeting like I
think they're gonna offer me a pilot
this is mental because I just thought it
was a general meeting yeah I got my car
and I rang my management up and I said
yeah it went really good and I'm driving
off the lot and I normally know how to
drive off the lot knowing and all of a
sudden I found myself behind the tour
bus like I'm down next to jaws and I'm
like oh fuck Canada get here these
people in golf carts driving it it's
symbolic you left it of meeting at an
executives office and that a shark yeah
I'm there like if I keep driving on this
road I'm gonna end up in the King Kong
machine they have like God can someone
give me a solid
going down the Desperate Housewives
Street something I'm definitely lost and
I ended up in the car park for
superstore you know come like a they
have the bit at the front I was in the
carpet and I just I had to get off the
lot and I did you know these kind of
poignant about that story is that
something that anyone sort of interested
in television and if you're listening to
this you probably are is that these
companies make their money off of theme
parks they don't make it off of
television that's their main moneymaker
is it that's when it gets humbling we
know they make their money sometimes off
of merch from their branded
but their theme parks Disney makes their
money off Disney Land right MBC makes
their money off Universal Studios not
from our little show water brother make
enough friends yeah they're literally
they're animation the new the new
friends thing that they go they're going
to do it and unscripted and you're like
what are you talking about unscripted
that's what like the tour I know you
probably know more you probably know
many of the friends I know let's have it
yeah but I'm this is like my podcast is
going to be this is unscripted well
they're not gonna do like a Larry David
thing where everyone just has an outline
and you know Joey's been me too right
that would have to be the first thing
Joey's been me to Drew and so so I think
they should this is what they should do
yeah let's just get together into a
Thanksgiving episode because they're not
all gonna live next door to each other
they're gonna have kids and stuff like
that it's a different era of life they
live in the suburbs they get together
for Thanksgiving and they all have a
meal and then there's some fights and
some things are brought up yeah that's
what I reckon a friend's fan I like
friends yeah do you like friends in
Britain it was so big in Britain it was
much bigger than sorry for anything Wow
when I was living in Britain it was on
TV just on repeat yeah certainly and so
I watched a lot of friends yeah Lisa
Kudrow would be a good person for you to
have on your podcast of you talk she
actually knows a ton about Neurology
Lisa Kudrow's brother is like the
number-one migraine doctor in the world
really
he's the Lisa Kudrow of my great doctors
in that wild I don't get migraine so I
don't need me it's just I remember he
deal with a D but so okay so I'm
fascinated by this because I want to do
another multicam also because but I
think that people don't understand that
a lot of times multicam fail because
people hire actors that have not
performed in front of a live audience
and I think that's when multi cams
really go right I think the secret of
friends was it wasn't the most amazing
writing the writing was good but that
was the best cast ever to it beers the
chemistry put together isn't so a lot of
times in Hollywood they go we want to
check this box and want to check check
this box and this girl's audition was
really good having a good audition in a
room with two people is not the same as
performing in front of an I also think
that
they can over concept sitcoms cracked
and so like Seinfeld was just for people
living in New York mm-hmm what's going
on with their life that's right friends
was just six people
yeah certain age was Mendes like now
it's like it's like I like the good
place right I think that's a good signal
now I'm getting a bit like I'm like I
missed one of them I find that
fascinating because it's very simple and
I love talking about this because
there's such a like critical like shame
around multi cams when that's what
people want to fucking watch it called
hockey for doing multi-campus it comes
in history women's cheers Seinfeld
friends Frasier these things were
brilliant vodcast studio yeah these are
brilliant brilliant shows yeah we all
loved and now we're meant to go they're
lame the problem is there's been some
shitty ones that's crap there's also
been a shitty single contract the
problem with the shitty multicam single
is there's shit jugs and then they still
people laughing I'm gonna in defense of
a lot of people that make multi cams
worked on other multi cams and and the a
lot of people are getting a little bit
dubious about the last cuz they think
it's like a laugh track track there's a
lot of audience I got a lot of shit for
that but it's because there's too many
microphones in the audience so you do
have to take some of the microphones out
of the audience is it with the Jim
Jefferies show people would go oh I
can't handle this laugh track we have
150 people in the audience every single
time that's right and so we started just
to show when we pan from the audience
when the opening credits just because
we're like fuck you I love that and I
also I learned that like you you do have
to change up the joke sometimes on show
night because if you're doing a second
take which is like doing another doing
it again basically they sort of know
what the joke is coming and they laugh
too soon but they laugh sooner than the
audience at home yeah I I've never acted
in a multicam I wonder whether I'll
enjoy it and I assume I will but it's
it's just like they'll understand up
right it's just like yes or kickin it
with the crowd yes did you used to do
your own warm-up yeah yeah I already in
crystally overdo it yeah on between yeah
I warm up on there Jim Jefferies all
right I used to do it and people like
kind other hosts
I do that I'm like why wouldn't they if
you want the audience on your side
that's right we want them to like you
well that's our instant sort of that's
our thing you know that's a muscle that
we have I did sometimes start to do it
less because when the audience is like
too juiced and they're laughing too hard
cuz they're there then in post I'd
actually end up trying to take the last
down because the person at home it's
like stand-up specials like you know I
try to I don't usually shoot in super
big venues because I don't want to be
like the last feeling my specials I
never do in like a rain is rainy - I
always do really small a one to two
thousand seats because I don't want air
to be a such a big discrepancy between
how the audience is laughing at home and
the people that are there it's never
gonna be the same yeah as the people
that are there and I think people fall
into that trap with specials where they
want to brag they want to show off this
is what I do my pet hate at the moment
with stand-up comedy comics is looking
at their Instagram if they have a big
audience and there's a photograph of
them fucking standing in front of a
schoolís thing you can do any comic who
has just gotten success when you're
doing that you look like a dick I'm
saying this out of love fucking stop
that look let other people post that you
did a big room I'm about to do the o2 in
London huge that's a big fucking gig for
me back for you I will not be a picture
where I'm like do your fucking show and
get off don't do it it's so it's so self
aggrandizing and it's also like a lot of
times because comes we've been doing
this long enough so like you know they
can give out Groupons and free calm like
I always I'm just like how do we know
those are all sold tickets whatever have
a bit of mistake about is well yeah well
you're good about that most P to say
when you're successful is you um okay so
so you know what's happening friends
okay okay just tell me if this is right
it's one episode and it's the first time
they all made a black person in terms of
all this because you're about to go
through this on your show and casting
your show and stuff right it's like
there is a very big push for diversity
in Hollywood and I have a really hard
time delineating what's performative and
what's real and what's genuine and
what's forced and I think that when
someone writes a show about you know
three white people or whatever they're
okay
and that's your experience
and I'm not saying it's good I'm not
saying it's bad but then the person the
network is like can you make one of
these people diverse I got well I had
the same issue with legit knowledge it
was really just three main characters
and then there was politics and stuff
like that and girlfriends and you know
other people in the world and we had so
it was me and two brothers and they
asked if one of us could be black and I
said well two of us can but one of us
can't because they're brothers
they're genetically related and I'm me
and you've already cast me hmm so we
can't make one of them black yeah good
point someone made that note to ask for
one of the two people to be black when
we went out with two Broke Girls a very
big network executive said we love it we
love it can it be two boys just
interests of the notes we get our but
I'm just very torn and maybe I'm not the
person to speak on it but it just sort
of like if you're just gonna write
someone as a white person and then go
well now we're gonna cast a black person
to try to seem like we're progressive
it's like well now you need to rewrite
it because you're implying that they
have the same experience yeah and that
to me is sort of like erasing an
experience it's like the complaint a lot
of people had about The Cosby Show back
when that was the biggest complaint was
that they sort of perceived it as if
black people were fine whenever they're
doctors now the lawyers we're good
that's the whole thing wasn't it like
good times was then the Black Panthers
visited Norman Lee all right then he had
to make the Jeffersons no because the
Jeffersons were the good times with a
bit of cash that was the whole thing
they wanted to show black people
succeeding I just am very like you're
about to go into production on a pilot
and you're gonna you're gonna go through
all this I don't mind the night schools
man I'm alright with it
I am I tell you what i just did a
natural man there i don't when i went in
the in the jim jefferies show whenever
there was a script one of our writers is
obsessed that I use the word man
organically which is more northern
English okay how so like a man okay like
that write it someone had a problem at
that one night someone liked it so they
used to put it in the scripts all the
time so the script would always say
okay yeah and so then Mitch McConnell
did this thing what's up with that man
and but if I had to read it I couldn't
say it properly I thought you meant
someone was like triggered by the word
man is like the new c-word no no no no
they wanted to put in because they
thought it was cool how I said it well
they just wanted to write in the way you
talk yeah and I could never read it well
no if you make me say it it's not like I
can only do natural Crikey's as well and
they happen every now and again I can't
rate a Crocky like I say how dare you a
lot I'm just so stupid just like what as
a joke and I remember when I was doing a
show people would write it in and it was
like no that's not where we're going but
you don't mean yeah I think people try
to write to your mannerisms or write to
you yeah how dare you like no I don't
think you say how dare you were like
well it just would be like how dare you
like just oh yeah yeah it's just like if
someone would disagree with me and be
right to be like how dare you like I
don't even know when I say it and I
think I do say I don't I don't know
about that and I find that's why I'm
calling the podcast that I say that a
lot and that's a great way to get out of
arguments
I'm not concede especially when you know
you're wrong there's so much Briggs in
facts you go well I don't know about
that so I can't be a cowboy I'm a moron
so I'm gonna stick to my bad opinion and
not only that I get points for admitting
I don't know yeah for conceding that you
maybe you're smarter than me but I'd
have to check on I'm now better than you
because I'm self-aware yeah exactly you
know but I do think so few people are
willing to say they don't know about
something it is such a fucking breath of
fresh air when someone is just like you
know I don't know enough about that to
weigh in yeah I'm like dude I love you
why do I love someone that doesn't know
anything in a little minute or that does
need to know much people can just sort
of check up and get whatever opinion
they they hit first on Google but I
think everybody feels this need to have
an opinion about every topic even though
they know absolutely nothing about it
this girl in Boston just stopped the
show she was an eighteen-year-old
Booker of some kind and she walked out
for every comic who's said anything that
she deemed to be misogynistic and she
canceled the show
and so obviously then I start getting I
get the calls
[Laughter]
fucking get the gold I get the calls
when someone gets me to their like
Whitney was that fair I'm like don't
fucking drag me and yeah yeah I get the
call and I don't like giving opinions
and everything I'm like I I would have
had to have been there I probably don't
agree with this and then I'm like I
don't really want to talk about it to be
honest
hmm I'll back myself to say anything on
a podcast or radio you can hear
intonation yeah oh that's smart but I
don't trust anybody who's printing
something yes this is fucking a sentence
yeah you're in trouble
I do find though audiences or I was at
the Comedy Store
whatever a couple months ago and there
was a comedian on stage that was doing a
joke about fat chicks you know it's this
whole bit about fat chicks and the woman
what this woman the audience just went
can you please stop she's a wild ma I
didn't fear but not is that what she
didn't stand up I don't know I didn't I
just remember getting really awkward and
Tim stopping and keeping doing the bit
and then bombing and then change the
subject and I was like oh this is this
is it now you know I have a bit about
gay conversion therapy at the moment
where the start of it sounds like I'm
agreeing with it but obviously there's a
twist
yeah M night Shyamalan a comedian
there's a twist and I'm not a moron the
disguise up and I some height speed yeah
a little bit of redeeming so the whole
thing of like I now have to say if I'm
making a point that's unpopular or that
sounds like it's not like you know
mainstream after just give me a second
yeah it's like it's like the joke starts
with I think gang conversion therapy is
the right thing to do and then this guy
just stood up and went no you're known
for saying something that's like gonna
be incendiary and then proving it just
give me a sec what do you think this is
all I've got right yeah I think I'm just
gonna give this one state you know I
don't have a punch line that's gonna
redeem me or make you feel better or
otherwise you would just be trying to
get canceled because you need a break
like the guy from mash that wore a dress
every day oh yeah you're just going out
there like someone canceled me so I can
get a vacation I just love that that was
that was like how is he insane he's
wearing a dresser it's so fucking like
phobic now that you look out about
Everett in 1950 that were like back
that's the whole thing like even
during Vietnam yeah I've got shin
splints right that's how Trump got out
right shin splints that's how he was
right that's how he got to drugs that's
how he dodged the drug huh I would just
go I'm gay I would have just gone gay
right away why do I have to have like a
medical condition where I have a limp
you know you don't have to have to
fucking pretend and there are plenty of
jobs to do that don't involve physical
exertion it was illegal to be guy in the
Army I want to just go out okay all
right go back and comfort all the women
seven ninety percent of the male
population is gone go tell them they
look pretty today do you get out of jury
duty do I got a juried yeah I've never
been asked um I don't know if I would
get out of it I think I'd probably go
you'd want to go curious to do it you
know you should not be a juror now that
you said you disagree with the last
person that you here
oh no no no I'd be terrible whoever has
the last closing statement they're the
winner was the citizenship test hard
citizen shop ah it was it was not know I
wasn't hot yeah it was five questions
out of that's it yeah but you have to
learn a hundred and they can ask you any
random one oh no baby was like ten
questions you have to get eight of em
rod or something but it was like it was
pretty easy yeah and I had to you know I
had to study mm-hmm and then I I learned
everything and most of the things were
pretty easy yeah but then like you know
like when they say name you know three
Native American tribes
I was trying I was trying to learn like
some more weirdo names listen what I got
Cherokee Navajo cars yeah yeah I picked
like ones that were really weird so the
guy would be like yeah this black guy
got a fetish like what the fuck like
that is such a crazy thing to ask for a
citizenship like name all the tribes of
people we slaughtered there's a lot of
like named three wars that America was
involved in in the last century you know
that's pretty easy yeah but that's just
such a love that they're just like it's
a greatest hits of all the horrific shit
we want you to know about our flaws
we're at 22 2009 you scare people off 20
of the 100 questions the answer
president so if the if the question
starts with who is the like who is in
charge of checks and balances president
who is the head of the military it is
kind of scary I think if I took the
citizenship I'd probably like what's the
name of your governor like like a few
years back everyone was like who's your
local representative and you don't know
that's the upside of having celebrities
run for office you can read Lou
Ted Lou is my guy when I became citizen
Ted Lou ha ha and it turns out I did
research and it turns out that a month
earlier I interviewed him on my show no
I did he was my guy what's I am I
allowed to ask you questions about your
show or not actually
details about I was just gonna ask you
what your jobs gonna be on the show at
the market that's a really hard it's a
really hard things I know you were
photographer on yours and it probably
was something before that something
before I love that you know that because
it's like for me it was just like it was
so many jobs are so fucking elitist and
I feel like an every TV show someone's
an ad executive or like works for a
magazine the big thing now is like they
started an app like I was just trying to
figure out a job that was like still
artistic because I couldn't they told me
I wasn't allowed to be a comedian on it
well I'm still a woman being a comedian
they're not into maybe I'm not into me
being a Comic Con and either I was a
comic on legit yeah and now I'm still be
a stand-up comedian I'll still be myself
but I'll be a late-night show host see I
was gonna that's where I was gonna pitch
yeah because I think once people know
you too well and then all of a sudden
you're like a construction worker
everyone's like why is this riche guy
produce the cool thing about having a
show like mine or like John Oliver's a
Samantha bees or some of those shows
yeah and and networks now have had
there's been so many mockumentary stuff
and you get so much information out by
going straight down the camera this is
what my day was like and you can't do
that no multicam because it's obviously
not mockumentary yeah but you can do it
on your TV show and talk about your week
that's and then cut back to so you can
still use that device without it being
mockumentary that's smart that's smart I
always loved Larry Sanders I was you of
the way that they you know I feel like
it's been a long time since there's been
like a
Sandri it's true it's very true one of
my favorite shows ever and did it really
well in a way that it didn't feel like
hokey and it felt organic but it just
can't be about the job but that might
change who knows but notes and
everything it might mush you come out of
there fucking fireman Jeffries a doctor
like stethoscope it's like my brother's
a cop and he's always had a chip on his
shoulder about firemen yeah because the
women like the firemen yes he's like
just fuckin putting water on things
fucking the cops no one secksy to some
people yeah for the most part you're in
trouble when you're around cops it's you
associate fireman with being saved
the problem with cop is I remember this
happened when we were making the NBC
show where they kind of wanted someone
that had a job where it was obvious it's
like some crazy note I don't remember
and we ended up I wanted blue-collar
people in the show I grew up watching
Roseanne I loved Roseanne I come from a
blue-collar family like I didn't want
everyone to just have some like you know
trust fund job like a job that doesn't
actually pay the bills where people
don't actually have to like press
buttons during the day and make shit
happen and so we ended up having someone
show the car the problems if you have a
cop on the show they always look like a
stripper that show if you see a guy in a
cop outfit show up at the door they
always look like they're in the like
Village People like it never looks so it
always just likes money
I wasn't like because life's stressful I
feel like in sitcoms the people have to
have jobs where they're worried about
being fired or that that's correct
a chick's coming and being in TV you
constantly at the risk of being fired
that's right that's right
that's so true so that's a good thing
you don't want to have it like like in
friends they still did that Monica lost
a job every five minutes and had another
restaurant you never really know
Chandler wasn't in there the Joey at
some stage is successful and then he
couldn't get health care I always liked
what they did with swimmers character
where we got like I bought that like I
like the job as the teacher he was the
only time he had a breakdown was when he
just lost his mind yeah and then he went
on a sabbatical yeah but you have to
make the job matter like I used to get
in like things with executives all the
time or say I've never watched it
because they're like we need to know
what their job is and we need to know
what their job is and what is their job
and I just never watched a show and be
like but what do they do
I didn't know what they'd do my
girlfriend does this when we watch films
I'll be watching like the mandalorian
and she goes I haven't seen him 8 ok you
never talks he's hanwen up how does he
ate you don't ever see me oh you haven't
seen him have a piece you know I know
he's doing it you know I fucking love
that because I think that what someone
eats and the way they eat is so
informative of their character my ex
Kate Hanks mom she can't fire movies
she's not good at it and so early on the
relationship I you see what's going on
this but I used to try to explain it and
then I just got into a mode where I just
made up a film that she might like to
see like I was just thinking with all
youse two are in love can I get together
later on I'm talking about a TA I don't
know what's going on I'm the worst
person to watch movies with because I've
done this too long and I can see when
something's ADR I can tell when
something's been looped I can tell when
something's a reshoot or a pickup and I
only look at continuity now it's like
when they cut the camera away and then
you hear the bass go that guy's crazy
yeah you always know it's ADR if you're
not on the face of the actor while
they're talking you know that's
something that for people who don't know
what a TR is they put it in later
because the story didn't make sense in
some way I'm not good at oh yeah I'm
awful at looping ADR I'm pretty good
never done a cartoon I have heard you
for me it was it was something that
ended up not happening it was the guy
that ran the company got me to it was
like one of the it was not cars not
planes it was some anthropomorphised
machines planes it was automobiles
offices with looks something and what
they did though was you went in and you
had to do it and they animated based on
your movements so I didn't have to match
to something that was already met you
afterwards I just did one but it's
coming out next year but I don't know if
I'm any good but like do you know what
Anna is an animal or is it I'm playing
an animal an Australian animal and I
think I mean I have a gasps yeah it's
got many Australian animals a watch did
you say how many astray
anger is Kaunas that's righti in target
10 it's one of ten I just mean in terms
of famous once famous ones this large
kookaburras a Miss Australian animals
that are animals that are everywhere
else I can list you 20 Australian
specific okay wombats I mean the dummy
rules now platypuses know are those
uniquely Australian yeah I didn't know
that very uniquely platypuses yeah I've
never seen one in the wall don't either
by they're very endangered kidness
what's that it's like it's like our
version of a hedgehog okay yeah we have
a little kidneys but I think a muse but
here's what I'll say I have a Hollywood
brain and I go to four quadrants and I
go what you're the ones that are gonna
be the most known we can't it'll be we
can't go too esoteric what sibility
bilbies like a little tiny outback mouse
with great big ears Trey we get
chocolate bilbies because we believe
that the Easter Bunny and we still have
the Easter Bunny but we believe that the
bill becomes and helps out a little bit
what if you start crying I have a dream
to go to the pink Lake that's in
Australia Google the pink Lake Australia
please thank you the way you get or get
cured from breast cancer it's no that's
the NFL it's a lake oh there we go that
because of the sulfur and the bacteria
the light hits it a certain way so it
looks pink I haven't seen Westerners
strike I never went to university it was
incredible
that is incredible in a wild finish I'm
like on the pink thanks the colors ponen
the water looks pink even when bottled
uh-huh
can you drink it I don't imagine you can
drink it I wouldn't it's something about
the bacteria and the way the light
refraction it then it turns pink I'm
surprised it's not alone Matthew
Flinders discovered it in 1802 is that
cool he discovered it the aboriginals
had no knowledge of it before he came
along and discovered it and white guy
saves the day again in that cool yep
it's because the bacteria algae
halobacteria
and other microbes and the amount of
salt I don't see anyone swimming in it
no I would imagine you would die
instantly
but the salt is like the Dead Sea yeah
it doesn't pose any danger to humans
there you go flirting it as the Dead Sea
look at me teaching you shit about
Australia but I got the dead say thing
you did you're winning
no one is a score of who's right I
floated around in the Dead Sea that was
how was that it's okay yeah I was drunk
and it was like I thought that was
closer than it was and it was like we
were in a bar and it was like three
o'clock in the morning and I just on his
Big Show in Tel Aviv haha and which I'm
also performing in Tel Aviv coming up in
a couple of months still many tickets
event will you tell us the date it's
like I want to say December 24 December
20th yeah
and so so what happened was it's in this
bar and I was like I should see the Dead
Sea in like the the security guy that
was with me and he's like oh it's two
and a half hour drive away oh it's a
two-hour drive away and you guys you're
checking out of the hotel at 11:00 you
won't have time and then it was like
four o'clock and I go what time is the
sunrise you know 6:00 and then I just
got on a table and said who wants to go
the Dead Sea and then I went out to like
I was like fucking Arthur or Richard
Pryor in Brewster's Millions
and I I booked all the cabs and I got
everyone in the bar and we all did it we
all drove up to the Dead Sea together
and we all got naked and floated around
as the Sun came up when was this like
two years ago are there pictures on your
Instagram we know I have pictures of it
but it was that was a quite a debauched
evening good morning
you seem fucking fun as shit yeah that
was a fun I could never do that I could
never then I was covered in salt and
stuff for me I'll be back just in time
to get picked up and you know a shower
and I just remember being feeling all
salty on the plane yeah that guys just
feeling a bit gross and I came home and
I just think of like cold water and
where's the place you haven't been that
you want to go I'm gigging Athens
I've never been to Greece well that's
the day before the day after Israel I
think it's a day before Israel yeah yeah
we were doing this too and we leave on
the 27th we're doing 18 cities or
something around round rambling around
the
Europe yeah I've never been to Greece
and I'm digging in Prague for the first
time I've been to Prague but I've never
giggling product and I was sued probably
supposed to be unbelievable I was in
larger drugs and I was like 22 when I
went there and I can't really remember
it I've got photos but it's it was
beautiful the old town was really
beautiful yeah and so I feel like lots
of like rich people go to Prague now
it's like the new Italy or something
yeah it's it's a fancy place no Blake
Griffin what there
I'm never gigged well so my gig not
another gig I'm doing a Belgrade mm-hmm
so that's you've been in Belgium it
right I've been a Belgian many times
yeah yeah Belgium's are beind abilities
I've probably done 15 gigs and better
I sell very well in Amsterdam yeah toys
that's why I was full of Dutch people I
noticed the first time that I performed
in Scandinavia I was member I was in
Stockholm and I was like doing my bits
very slowly oh no no and they were like
we've speak better English than you you
fucking idiot
the Scandinavian people because they all
like death metal and I was tough yeah
they come up to me after the shows and I
sort of I'm there every two years
yeah about my fourth trip there hello
and they come up and they go they go
yeah we enjoyed it the show was good you
know but I gotta tell you I was more
offended last year and you're like oh I
didn't know what's coming to offend you
Wow oh I'm sorry shock me if a lot of
people do that to me and they're like I
want you to roast me I'm like now you
don't yeah yeah no you don't know it's
not nice yeah but I think I I think I'm
glad you're saying that I think it
should be said more because I think a
lot of bloggers and woke culture justice
warriors forget that a lot of people
just want to fucking hear something shot
yeah they want to be offended they want
to be sharp they want it it's haunted
houses a comedy they want to feel like
it's on the edge and anything can kick
off and on tosod and that's why camera
finds sort of ruin it because we used to
live in this room where okay we're going
through this experience together and it
doesn't leave here Couric's used to get
naked yep that's right Bobby Lee still
does used to get naked on stage right
now with camera phones you can't do that
or did you do there yonder bags or
whatever if you want to be a Canton fuck
posted I'll have someone try to take it
down and we'll move on with our life but
I don't I don't like people holding
their phone I understand when you walk
out they all take a picture yeah
it's that person you put that down you
only have to tell one person yeah that's
right then everybody gets then that
person just looks to you like what why I
had the craziest experience in Miami
where there was this group of girls they
were like drinking shame in Miami the
shows always start later like it started
mine my I'll say like something adorable
my son because I always call it Miami
and when I'm going to gig there my son
guys are you going to your Remi just
exploded that's so cute
oh ah and I was there once and this show
started like 9:00 right usually it
starts like 7:00 7:30 Abe and these
girls were videoing and it was like I
usually if you just look at them and go
like they'll kind of get the hint if you
just like make eye contact with that and
they kept going and kept going and I was
like I haven't done this in a special
yet and it's kind of annoying so I
finally just said something I was like
you know could you guys stop filming we
can do videos afterwards and they looked
at me they're like oh no we're filming
ourselves yeah yeah I was like oh my bad
for a second here I thought I would be
the entertainment or the thing you would
want to capture on camera they were
taking selfies of themselves watching
the show and I was so arrogant to think
they might be filming me I think I think
specials are going to go the way of like
Andrew shorts is doing it where you just
release a little bits of material yeah I
love Andrew I think that people now have
such short attention spans and because
everyone's recording anyway you might as
well self-release might as well release
two minutes
fucking a week and then you go the
specials there it's kind of fucking I
mean it doesn't mark on me because my
bits are so long or so long yeah but I
also think I find like as a comedian
when you you know build up an hour takes
you know eight months or whatever
there's so many talk shows now and
there's so many people doing jokes all
the time that by the time you release
something a bunch of people might have
already done jokes about that yeah you
know I found by the time I do this big
chunk on sex robots and like nobody was
doing it by the time it came out it
where do you keep the robot I've seen so
many pictures if she's downstairs you
want to go fuck her no the last thing
I'll say about Scandinavia is I remember
I went over there and when I went to
mature Thor she's really actually way
more fun to talk to you than me and she
knows a lot more and what she says is
actually true
when I went to Norway you've been there
right yeah in Bergen they don't have
strip clubs like there was this thing
where I was like reading about and
trying to write jokes specifically for
Norway and and I got the phone with some
journalists I was like hey why don't you
guys have strip clubs you fucking
pussies like I was like you know writing
some jokes about it and he was like oh
well over here we respect women like I
don't follow like I didn't understand at
the time so much of my tear material was
about being disrespected and I had this
whole joke about how when you're
fighting with a guy and they hang up on
you and then you know it's just kind of
like how you fight or something and it
was fucking bombing and I finally in I
think it was Sweden I was like why are
you guys and they're like yeah guys over
here don't do that would you know in
Sweden they brought in a law now where
you have to ask for permission to change
positions during sex
because I was trying to write a bit on
that you have to consent for each
position so you're having sex
everyone's consenting hmm and then
you're doing doggy style you start and
then you want to change into mich you
can't just flip her over you gotta go we
gotta go into mission area you sign off
I I do think though there's a lot of
women that are ashamed to maybe admit
like a lot of women want to just be
thrown around and have their hair pulled
I mean most a lot of my guy friends now
they'll call me like hey I'm dating this
girl and she wants me to hit her and he
wants me to choke her and is this a trap
am I about to get sued like a lot of
women do like things kind of rough and I
don't know about that I know I know we
have to go but I do think like as I can
say this because you can't fucking
cancel me for saying this is there are
women that like to have men be alphas
and just like take them no and then
there's guys that like that women tread
over their backs to be called maggot
north of I've never understood that oh
guys being a submissive yeah I've never
understood
oh no there's a big thing where guys
want to be humiliated or no I think
that's like a mom issue thing that's
like a call your mom work it out yeah
you know getting shit on and all that
you're gonna have a podcast soon so you
want to practice ending a podcast
episode uh you've been listening to
Whitney Cummings podcast which is called
good for you
[Laughter]
thank God I put download the cash app
for free
Oh for free on the App Store or Google
Play market ten dollars for you ten
dollars for The Trevor Project yeah look
at that we're also doing something good
anything else you want to do the
oblivious tour starts in January and
great title anyone who's like shit I'm
going on tour March and I'm just like I
better pull it together they go what's
it about and I go I don't know funny
and so the night talk or two is still
going on in Europe that one's very
polished yeah the end of its run why cuz
you're gonna shoot at the end of it and
I've already I've already shot a new
special ok I've shown you special but I
don't believe it'll be out till February
March or something like that so will you
tell the title of it or do you keep it
secret um I think I can tell the title
you always have fucking amazing the new
titles called intolerant great I know
I'll tell you why we did we get off the
line ok thank you everyone love you
don't write elephants
[Music]